this is going to be the spring Marathon
2023 I will admit that I'm a little bit
under the weather
I've had a lot of travels recently and
last like day or two
haven't been feeling 100 so
I'll see how long I can stay awake how
long my voice can last
I'm prepared with with uh with water and
also some like chai tea
I think the chai has been brewing for
long enough
also prepared with Kleenex hopefully I
don't need this Kleenex too much
but it is a season of allergies so the
Turman started
about 19 minutes ago
so I'm Lee joining but I still have
many hours to Place some chess so if
you're watching in the future on YouTube
uh congratulations for clicking on what
will probably be a very long video
this is a spring marathon it's a 24-hour
long tournament
I don't know how long the eventual
YouTube video will be but
as usual I'll time stamp every single
game in the video description uh
hopefully with the opening and the
opponents so please leave a comment what
your favorite game is in this video
and no more wasting any time let's hop
in
my bullet rating is 2800 exactly and
this is two minute rated bullet so it's
not the classic one minute and it's not
three minute but it's kind of an average
wait let me put in my earbud I don't
have any sound
okay we have a pirates
here we go
um oh this is like a what do they call
this
a philodor
Okay so
actually this is the opening that jobava
played in oh what did I already go wrong
I may have already gone wrong
H3 is coming though
okay so we both lost a couple Tempe
Joe Bava played this against me in Abu
Dhabi and that game I went for this
queen B1 Queen A2 idea
this game I'm gonna play a little bit
more traditionally
uh Rook D1
this is what jobava told me to do after
our game
and just play normally
maybe I can take
yeah let's take
and some Knight H4 I'm subjecting myself
to maybe some tactics but
as far as I can see the tactics don't
quite work for black takes takes
takes and then Knight D6
okay let's play another five
already dreaming of sacking and mating
Pleasant position fully developed
all the pieces are
kind of happy here
uh do I go all in take take
might as well
this might be dubious but it might be
very strong because after it takes takes
I'm hitting both nights
although then there's Nyla 4 but then I
checkmate
also getting a big time Advantage here
question are you gonna play the whole
Marathon
uh well you'll just have to keep
watching and find out
this is game one if you're in the try
and conserve energy
uh okay that's a good sign
The Bishop's not being consumed so
I can take and essentially be up upon
so seven pawns against six Pawns
up a lot of time here too
thank you chess and beers
I probably won't be drinking any beer
this stream
but I'll try and compensate that with a
lot more chess
okay let's trade
and then Fork
speaking of fork here's a spoon
use it to stir your honey into my tea
it's another Fork
okay double legging zero rating
it's a problem with being 2100 I view
the 2200 and it doesn't count for
anything but maybe I gained like a
fraction of a point
so whoa another game started I had the
tournament open in a new tab
okay
um so new game not much break what is
this
D4
okay opponent is just going full ham
mer uh always on passant
uh oh
okay always develop the king
I mean If This Were King of the Hill
King D5 would win the game
okay Queen D3 is such a nice move
ooh okay let's defend
what a weird game
D4 might be coming although probably not
uh
what is this position
okay I'm gonna artificial Castle
uh
I'm up two pieces
okay how to do this
oh no my Bishop
so Queen H3 is coming yeah
play this move
White's gonna sack everything
wow
wait I should be careful here is Maiden
one
I just simplify
take
you just simplify
not my promise technique
but opponents gifted me uh-oh
okay upon this gifted me more than
enough though
so I can dig The Rook
I'm still kind of waking up
if I'm up a rook now
or is in Queen trade
primoves will come
okay hey it's Z Nation
for 66 months welcome back Z Nation Jess
the OG sub of the channel
I'll come back Misha zero
happy one year and your tablet 39 months
Young Gun with 18 months
so again if you're just joining I played
two games thus far
um let's berserk let me try and climb my
way up the standings
opponent berserking back
okay
that might be my quickest game of the
tournament
was fearing the Stafford probably
okay
top 600.
there's over 5 000 players in this
tournament
if you want to join uh you can go
there's a few ways to join you can use
the join command
that will link the tournaments or go to
the leechas homepage
tournament is available there
um not gonna berserve too much these
first few games
thank you Christine HP
okay let's play a two nights
are we gonna see an ortho shot
Ortho Gambit time
no okay this is like um
what do they call this
like C3 is the main move
in Queen D7
I forgot the name of this opening
okay I have to be a little bit careful
I'm just castling
Queen H5 Queen F5
I am temporarily up a pawn here
foreign
yeah for those not familiar with
berserking
um it's a pretty common strategy in
tournaments like this to try and rack up
the tournament points
involves cutting the time and a half and
then if I win I get an extra point for
the tournament
but I'd rather not take too many risks
early on
wow
and my opponents are going super aggro
so Knight G5 I can take it
or queen F5
probably Queen F5 here
pinning the bishop
yeah two minute shots is a very
different time format to what I'm used
to
[Music]
hopefully I can get the hang of it
let's play F6 first
up a piece
so really the goal is to not blunder
anything not get mated
maybe simplify to the end game
Queen G4 looks nice
light could not avoid the queen trade
there
thank you Occam's sock'em robots
welcome back subbing for 31 months
okay I'm probably gonna win this game on
time
but maybe I'll try and like generate
some quick meets
quick meeting ideas
uh yeah D3
I got the Knight to E2
I don't think I'm gonna check these
before White flags
okay
well I managed to resign before flagging
so that's three games or wait no that's
four games
but one of the games was like a one
mover
playing Guido van h
uh
um
I might mix up the openings as
the stream goes on
at some point maybe I'll take requests
from the audience
but I gotta play some of the classics
first have a ponziani
the best beginner opening
Queen A4 is a fun move like even against
strong players
uh sometimes they don't know how to
react like de4 is already just a mistake
and White's winning upon
yeah develop Castle
[Music]
Queen is Happy on F3
hard for black to attack
Bishop F4
[Music]
yeah just being super super solid
I'll probably try and orchestrate some
attack on the king side like H4
I kick the Knight around
[Music]
okay
making progress
so when the Knight moves I can take the
bishop
I could take the bishop of the queen
how to do this
let's take with Knight first
there there
this first
and then Bishop F5
yeah the king is wide open now
still takes a bit of work
like I don't want to play H6 and allow
Knight G6
okay preventing any knife from moving D6
threatening to fork with a pawn
Queen side down to defending F6
a very difficult position for back
okay the Knight wants to come here but I
can play this
okay
hey I gained your rating point it only
took what five games ticking one reading
point
generally with Marathon tournaments I
lose a lot of reading because I berserk
a lot and inevitably I lose to low rate
of players
so I have to enjoy my 2800 plus rating
while it lasts
welcome back to Andrew
hey from Dominican Republic I saw um I
saw an Instagram and DM from Yvette hope
you guys are doing well
thanks for stopping by
okay I have to be mindful that I
berserked this game
so I'll try and be aggressive here
also thanks for the hype everyone
I appreciate all the subs and supports
Mark valoy welcome back
okay uh not quite winning the pawn
because the Rook comes in
maybe I can trap the bishop
okay now I win the pawn
and maybe a second Pawn
yeah life is good here
thank you ultimate pots are
I maybe could have taken the third Pawn
but
more interested in bringing the queen
into play
uh did I just blunder I think I just
plundered
oops
okay we'll trade Queens I'll lose a
bishop
but I have four pawns for the bishop
I still have all eight Pawns
always Castle
it's never too late to Castle
[Music]
okay I'm gonna try and win this game
without losing a single Pawn
will it be possible
wait can I get connect eight
I have 18 seconds though
honestly this is probably my closest
game of the tournament so far
I can't swim my lowest rated opponents
okay Rooks like to support pass Pawns
oh I lost a pawn
okay
that was a fun game
grew this to my opponent like played
well for the rating
so top 200
. I'll berserk again
we have a London jobava London
taken Bishop G4
okay so I won the pawn I want to play E5
and
control the center
maybe E4
E4 will Trot the bishop if White's not
careful
does promoting count is losing upon
yeah I've never thought of that but
every time you promote to a queen
you lose a pawn
that's kind of sad but also probably
kind of worth it
any predictions for this stream
probably not
I have no idea like what's gonna happen
so everything will be very unpredictable
I don't know how long I'm gonna go for
I do try and make sure I don't uh like
overdo it I don't want to burn myself
out too much
I do want to sleep at some point within
the next 24 hours
okay rookie it looks really nice
oh my point is in the chat look at this
hi I'm playing against you
the usernames match
hello to my opponents
hope you're doing well apart from the
situation on the e-file
no mercy here
let me make sure I don't plunder any
back rank mates
I'm probably gonna win on time
[Music]
but I'm gonna try and meet before White
flags
uh like this
gotta get the pieces into play
oh it's almost mate
and it's really close to Nate
where's my mate
it's made in two one two okay
I can count to two
okay games of my opponents
um
yeah Joe Bravo London's a trendy opening
these days
uh if you want to like study this
seriously I think the main moves are E3
and E4 I would probably recommend E4
it's like the most aggressive response
a Gigi
so trying to break the top hundred
uh playing a title player
I think my first titled opponent
I'm switching back to E4
I got a scandi
I don't plan to this line
I think this is called the leonhard
Gambit
opponent knows how to not plunder
but there's still some compensation I
would hope
got my Bishops
I think I'll play this maneuver to G3
and then try and
use the knights and the Bishops to
attack
when Queen's a little bit awkward
wow
Queen's just chilling on A3
okay I'm already some ideas of taking
the F Pawn
[Music]
yeah I like Knight H5 because it aims to
remove one of the only Defenders of the
king side
um
interesting
should I take the Knight
and take again
not super clear
this first
I just want to lift
okay I could take on E6
anything better
take on G7
and take on E6
yeah this is trouble for black
um
I actually didn't get like fully what I
wanted I just went back the pawn but
there's still a fight
oh a2's hanging
but do I care
I kind of care
but now I don't care
or do I have this move
oh no my queen
someone called ambulance
but not for me
yeah I think this is like resignable for
back
uh I'll take
okay
that was a cool move Queen C7
um all the pieces were under pressure
there
I gained another rating point
okay
at some point I'm gonna hit my Peak
rating this stream
hopefully that point comes later
okay playing godaga
I'm reaching the point where like every
game I'll probably be playing high rated
opponents
okay let's play the barman variation
I may be transposing yeah transposing
into Cambridge Springs
I've been doing a lot of like studying
in these lines
uh yeah E5
I was actually preparing to play the
design against Anna cramling
it's a tricky variation
okay so black should win back the pawn
there's a three
like after A3 I'm supposed to Castle
okay here I can take
probably have to take now
so we have an end game
the thing's kind of liquidated pretty
quickly there
uh not thrilled about this Pawn but
such is life
I have this move Rook da coming
oh no my Pawn
it's interesting position because I have
Bishop F3 I also have Rook T2
I think I'll start with Rook D2
so after it takes takes Rook D3 on
Bishop E2
okay now we play F5
I'm controlling the only open file which
should bode well for me
B5 C5
I'd rather not have other files open
closing everything down
pawns a potential weakness
a g file might open but that's fine with
me
Rook has access to G8
so if King H2 I have Bishop D3 hitting
the rook and the pawn and still
preventing Rook off one
okay now
yeah it's pin threatening this
and if the key moves
Bishop F3
I mean White's like very stuck here
at some point I'll probably play Bishop
F3
okay I'm just going after the pawn
there's King G1
okay that's a free Bishop
okay that was actually a very pleasant
game
um I played through pretty much all my
Cambridge Springs preparation
and it led to like in sort of liquidated
late middle game early end game
[Music]
where yeah black just had a more
pleasant position
so I gained another reading point
welcome back to NOAA constrictor welcome
back to Jay good to see you
so okay I'm at my Peak rating for this
tournament
but my Peak rating in bullet overall I
think is like just over 2900 on the
chess
so still a ways to go to get back to my
Peak
okay I'm playing an opening here that I
really have no knowledge about
some kind of real slimo
you play D4
a lot of Trades now
not sure if I want to trade Bishops
might as well win back the pawn
trying to tie down this bishop to
defending the pawn
Brook C might be played
in Bishop F4
I think the goal is just to develop and
then control D5 pressure the weak D6
Pawn
this Pawn is isolated and on the half
open file
H3 I think is a useful prophylactic move
okay threatening this stuff
and take with Bishop I could take on D6
take take
your no wait let's take care first
I will say this really doesn't feel like
bullet chess it's just faster you pay
splits
oh that move I didn't see
okay I'm losing back upon
95 there's some activity I have a double
threat oh I didn't see that move
but I have this move
attacking everything
okay
the tactics gods were kinds of me there
just stumbled into a good line
okay no mercy
I think the simple plan is to push the
pawn
okay
he gained another rating points
hey I was 64th Place
but now moving up 40 seconds
I think we found the meaning of life
thank you slash lore
yeah only 96 more games until 2 900.
okay playing Libra moon
let's mix up the openings
play the English
inspired by ding
ooh
oh this is uh
wait what's the theory here E5 let's
play F4
a weird version of Kings Gambit
I have no idea this is a theory but it
looks fun
just want a castle soon
okay we could be trading a lot
so my Bishop's Unleashed this Pawn is
also vulnerable
I think I'm happy with opening
I think you triple snake
happy 20 months
that's an interesting move
it takes takes
that's actually a good move
try this
I'm not sure what's going on actually
I'm still hitting the night
the positions opening up a ton
down a little bit of time
I might as well take
yeah we're trading off a lot of things
we probably have to trade Queens
so after all said and done it's equal
material
opposite color Bishops
I like this bishop Pawn combo
uh
you Rook here first
threatening meat
kind of this move
okay a lot of tactics in the position
trying to calculate the sign
I mean simple tactic but
okay
I'll move quicker
oh really
oh I I forgot my Rook was defended by
the bishop was defended by The Rook
it's a mobile 4 Rook here
okay
so I made a very bad pre-move there
okay it's almost mid but not quite
put the visit back on somewhere
okay
opponent didn't go for the dirty flag
yeah I got confused
um because I thought the I didn't see
the bishop was defended by The Rook
so I was expecting takes and I was going
to take and then I mean if
if black went for Rook C5 I would have
lost the
I would have been losing material
um
okay good fights
top 30.
thank you Yoda lives forever
how many people sleep to my videos
yeah how many people have already fallen
asleep right now
okay let's play do I berserk I'll have a
bullet game
vlogmar dimmer time
wait a minute
I got confused
this is not Theory
I've really messed this up
I should have played each five first
yeah this is an opening gone terribly
wrong but it's interesting still
I just want to win the pawn oops
93 may be coming
hmm
maybe two
it was dangerous
don't hurt me
okay
I took some work
yeah this might happen more often where
like we double berserk and then it's
just a one minute bullet game
two rating points for that
I'll take it
top 20. undefeated thus far
playing another title player this might
be my highest rated opponent
we'll uh switch to London or whatever
this is
this is a pterodactyl attack
oops I didn't mean to do that
how bad is this
Queen's like hustling was just a mouse
slip
and now I'm flustered
oh this is a really bad position
[Music]
that maybe can hold on
I think I'm holding on like just barely
now the queen defends Knight's pinned
I do lose that
I don't know
no
that was my first loss
wow my point was really faster
like really really fast
look at this point zero two seconds left
ah let me turn on my heart rate monitor
oh that was kind of sad
opponent deserves a win there for being
so fast
okay
have to calm down after that long
I had a good position to after stumbling
there goes my reading
and my streak
but we move on
playing Soul tie
Good Luck play Sicilian
okay this is some Theory
which I haven't looked at in a while
[Music]
I think Queen H4
or is it 94 first
in 194 first
I might just be confusing myself I think
I'm supposed to queenside Castle
eventually
okay here I win The Exchange
I did concede the dark spot Bishop
it feels like the king should be safe on
B7
kind of a weird position though
hmm
I don't know what to do
take on each three
maybe this first I don't know
the white definitely has compensation
[Music]
okay that's some success
my queen wants to be on D4
there we go
it's a free nights
oops
I blundered back material or did I
there
okay
should still be fine just down a little
bit of time
I have seven I check first
a little bit shaky
I think I'm getting things done here
oh mercy
okay
trying to inch my way back to 2800
welcome back to Kavita welcome back hot
Cheeto
happy 21 months
was there a free night mist
yeah I'm sure there are things missed in
that game
playing new Americana
I think this is the first Carol con I'm
encountering
okay we'll play this sign
so the idea is Queen R5 Queen E3
avoiding the queen drain
black can insist and then B3
this might be some Theory
Pleasant position though
I have the bishop here now and D5 might
be coming
yeah D5 looks really nice
and get the other Rook involved
also threatening to take take and then
Bishop D7 check
yeah this is like already close to
winning
castling
start with check
how to do this
C7
probably Rook G1 coming
yeah this bishop is going to prove
useful very soon
so obstructing The Rook from defending
if the king moves it walks into stuff
that's a move though
uh
I guess I have to take
[Music]
um
that's a good move
there there
it's not so simple like I lose back the
pawn
ah
I'm not even better here also my Rook
was just hanging oops
but how bad is it
oh it's pretty bad
uh oh
wait I'm not trying no I'm not trapping
the bishop
oh dear
this is really bad
still a little bit tricky though
that's a great move
oh no my Pawn
oh I got Maiden oh what to do
I hung a rook
yeah rookie won man that was such a good
position to
95 I just did not see coming
maybe you should have started with F4
and I didn't see how to save my Pawn
here
like it might already be
like not better for white
okay back to tournaments
oh things for the Dono to emburg
wishing a spectacular evening
not ready for pentatonic just yet
have to stay awake a little bit more
playing positional play
do I try and play tactically or
positionally
this is actually a more positional
opening
this is like a really fun line in London
um I think H3 is generally called for
and B5 is already a threat
yeah this is a very classic positional
approach
on the queen side B4 will come again
might as well take
the knights coming to D5
so I think I'm ready to train
and then maybe my king will just chill
on E2
I think delayed bong cloud
I'll take
Bishops coming to see southern
ah Bishop's coming to B5
not so simple
I'm wondering if the exchange stock will
work
like Rook B5
improve the king first
take take take
I'm not sure if it works
okay Switching gears
Kings misplaced
okay I was expecting rookie six
ah
now I might be in trouble
I'm in trouble here
maybe it's okay in time travel
okay
a little bit too slow
really
oh this isn't good
okay this is better
let's go okay
ah that took work
took a lot of work
oh
at some point I was kind of regretting
not taking the draw off her
but
I proved to be a good decision to
play for the win
it was very tricky position
[Music]
opponent like coped with the opening
pressure pretty well
I'm playing joyful scooter
welcome back I'll Capitan PDX
happy 44.
okay so we have a queen's gambiter
client
I'm gonna stick with this repertoire the
Cambridge Springs style although Bishop
D3 right away
will probably transpose into something
wow
I think I'm just winning a piece now
yeah I love the piece
there's a Venom of the Cambridge Springs
and all these tactical tricks
the queen on A5
swing over
light spores are very weak
lights missing the light squared Bishop
darkspurs are also kind of vulnerable
maybe this first
yeah it takes something made into
okay this is a nice game
um
yeah white has to be really careful here
Knight E2 just walked into the tactic of
hitting both Bishops and the Knight was
a Target
Knight F3 doesn't really help because as
takes takes in 94
so white probably had to take
a fun opening
trying to get back on a streak
53 tournament points
a leader has 88
are you planning on taking breaks
it would be impressive if I stream the
whole marathon without taking a single
break
probably won't happen though
okay back to a pet line
so I have the bishop pair
black has a little bit more space
it's probably roughly equal here
okay so I want to play Knight G5
F6 or H6 should have been played there
for black
because once I complain Knight takes
Bishop
it's two Bishops against two knights
develop
this move so this Knight's pinned
Bishop C5 is probably coming
uh is this when material
no it doesn't
I got three
we had this first
and Bishop C1
I want to play this and this
what wait what did I do
I don't know what I did there
unexpected hacking
uh takes there there I think this is
okay
so if here I take take and then pin
all right Knight C3 still might be
coming
or that move
I have this move
other than this move but then this move
I don't know what's happening
oh that's a good move
Bishop B1
my Bishop pair is not too impressive
yeah this is not great
and try and open the position
yeah that's a big problem
go
both nights are hanging oh everything's
hanging for black
so maybe I went back a night
I could move them
wasn't meant to be
dull there goes a bishop
it's almost stalemate ah let's checkmate
if I didn't have a bishop here it would
be still needs
really was not meant to be there
okay back to the meaning of life
plenty of time to try and work my way up
the standings
playing bug rovich
play E4
oh thank you zilfth with the tier one
sub
okay another two nights attack against
Carol Khan
um play C3
it's a more positional line I have the
bishop here
I think the plan is to steadily
improve
Queen D5 might happen
might have to take
we still have the bishop here
but positions like this can lead to a
long grinding
like end game
late middle game
so I'll gradually try and improve with
my Pawns
and my Rooks
play Rook D1
[Music]
yeah I don't want to trade off
maybe this idea
I'm not sure about Knight H5
okay
got my G4 moving
um
and try this
it's risky though giving away the B4
Square
maybe three first
okay this is something
a little bit down on time
it's more open position
[Music]
ooh
good move
foreign
there we go
I can't touch me if I stand light
squares
I got touched
no
that's stalemate
oh
oh the first stalemate travel of the
Stream
and I'm the victim
or who's the victim and maybe we're both
victims the holiday
[Music]
I should have played this move I was
made into
okay top 50.
my streaking this has slowed down a
little bit
but that's part of life
thank you agranak
oh playing this player again who's super
fast do I berserk back
try and get revenge
yeah this player like bugs me in a
situation where I didn't think I could
be flagged
okay this is a little bit questionable
Queen E2 coming
and probably a little bit worse here but
I'm up a lot of time
that's a good move
don't hurt me
wow
okay there's a lot of Trades
before is coming
okay
got the jobs on there got some
berserking points
welcome back to hamster him happy 22.
hope you're doing well
playing The Dark Knight Rise
uh um
what is this
oh wow
tricky opening
not sure what to make of this
okay F4 is coming
so Bishop her two Pawns
it should be in good shape
Queen a1's hard to stop
this is a funny move
if it takes it's made in two
if here
what's happening
I have this move now
the tactics are flowing
like a tactical waterfall
wow
that move just confuses me
I think it's a free Queen
there there
I was looking for mates but okay
I was uh it was an interesting game
weird opening led to weird middle game
thank you Dr Boogie fiva
happy 14 months
all right let's try and break into the
top 30.
it's been a while since I've been there
playing trapezunt
yeah this is way more positional
I think early Queen trade
uh
some
trying to figure out my plan
Bishop C4 first preventing Knight of
seven
now this
I might not be getting much though
allowing the trade
takes takes the night will be restricted
at least
now plan let's get this Knight to E3
and eventually F5
yeah there's some pressure here
it was very kind of long-term strategy
trying to use this F5 Square
I'm fixing the pawn on each side
this Pawn could be a weakness but it
could also maybe use strength
start by taking
and B3
oops just hung upon
yeah I'm not better here
I'll try and play on though
cause you never know
oh there's a funny line before
takes and then some mating ideas
okay
I'm trying to play for a win it's not so
easy though
there there
[Music]
I'm still not better
but it's getting a little bit unbalanced
let's get back to D7
opponent's taking time
that's a good move
I see fourth first
hmm
so it's equal material we both have four
Pawns
and it's getting spicy now
okay I managed to win on time
as a hard fog game I was a little bit
quicker
I think you lost my Gambit
oh asking Gambit time okay let's scan it
whatever my opponent does I'll play
what's the gamut I can play against this
Athens Gambit
Evans Gambit time
I don't know much about Evan's gambits
but I'll try and make it work
okay two pawns attacked is this really a
line
this might be online
's moving quickly
I'm kind of scared
I should be H5
that's a good move
I have this move
I have no idea what's happening anymore
I can take here
oops okay boat has ganned it
oh that's not what I wanted
uh oh dull my knight
I gambited too many things
what to do
hey it's Jules oh it's Jules Gambit
Jules Gambit is a much better Gambit
than whatever I'm doing here
but I'm playing on because you never
know
never as I'm when you have a rook
battery
oh no my perfect score this is my long
lost
adopted child
I played Houston many times
uh
let's play A4
uh oh
someone call an ambulance
especially for me
okay Pawn storming
okay opponent gave back a queen
they saw this pin but they didn't see
the other Arrow
and still lost though I'm down three
minor pieces and two Pawns
how am I not dead yet
I have 11 seconds oh it's meat okay
the King was bound to get mated
somewhere
okay note to self don't Gambit
everything
uh nobody's working let's try and get
back on track
we have a Four Knights
a very uh classical opening
this is a different move order than
usual
I don't mind this
not bad to commit to G5 when I haven't
committed to castling yet
damage the structure a little bit
yeah things look in Jewels for the raid
shout out to Jules I hope you had a good
stream if you're just joining this is a
marathon
of springtime
it's a 24-hour long tournament
uh I guess I trade Bishops
I joined I joined the tournament about
20 minutes late but
it could be a long stream at some point
I'll probably get some sleep
but who knows when that will be
there there okay let's defend
defend some more
and see file pressure could be some
issue
C4
I'm actually in a little bit of trouble
here
okay I have one idea Rook C1 Rook d8 not
sure if this works the ideas after takes
takes
yeah D3 would be a Target but not
anymore
hey Queen D7
ah this doesn't work though
okay I'm gonna be down the pawn
but Life Will Go On
I mean White's extra Pawn is a backward
d-pawn so
it's not that bad
a threes kind of weak
never mind
but I gotta move faster I'll slide in
this I should play Queen B1 first
and queen B1 King E2 and then Queen G1
yeah
uh good move
time scramble time
it's a race
oh no
my queen
oh the chess gods were not kind to me
yes it's still meat
oh the chest cards were very kind to me
I I was hoping for queenoff too because
that's like the standard ladder mates
by Queen H2 came as the surprise
but a very pleasant surprise
I still lost five rating points but it
could have been worse
okay playing a
okay have I not had a Stafford Gambit
yet
I don't think I have
staff or Gambit time the first Stafford
of the marathon
okay we got a very high rated opponents
falling into
what is a pretty lethal trap
no mercy here
at Bishop G4
I think this is GG
I mean Bishop C4 is like already a
losing move
surprisingly enough
okay let's take this
up a full Rook
uh
might as well trade
yeah the Knight gets trapped
okay
that was pleasant
yeah hopefully we'll have at least a few
more staffords before the end of the
Stream
so top 30
it's hard to work my way up I really
need to like try and get on a streak
have another scandi
play D4 this time
go for the sign
Bishop
there 95
I don't know exact Theory here
looks Pleasant though
welcome back to Fang Duster
hope you're doing well thanks for the
bits
welcome back to Pure happy 16 months
okay let's be aggressive here
E5 is probably coming
Queen G3 with a pin
okay this is essentially a pawn
sacrifice I'll lose G4
the hope is I get something in return
but maybe it's it's not so simple group
D2
and Knight of two is a big threat there
now I'm down upon my Pawn sacrifice
didn't really work
uh before
I might as well
so it's three on two
the goal is to make a passer and then
win the race of the past Pawns
okay this move
so the Knight can venture to C5 perhaps
that's a good move
uh
D5
it's interesting still
[Music]
um
it was very interesting
foreign
I just played way too slowly towards the
end there oh what to do
back to the almost meaning of life
okay 44th
all right let's try and get a streak
try and untilt
this is the best way to untilt hopefully
staff again at the time
opponent seems prepared
uh or maybe not
opponent got a little bit confused
here
wait now what do I do here
this is probably a
one way to punish this
that's a pork
a pin plus a fork
okay 13 moves to offered win
so far the Safford is unbeatable today
I'm delivering me some like quickest
wins
I feel untilted now
yeah I never resign when you have the
Stafford gambits oh playing a 3 000
rated plus player
interesting
I just hung upon
that's not good
now what have I done
and we're trading a lot
I mean I probably have to go all out now
there there
[Music]
not the move I wanted to play
I really want to play F4
let's try this
take
okay some kind of tricky trick worked
out
what's happening though
I'm somehow up material now I'm off the
exchange
Rogue A7 Rook C2 looks strong
Rook B8
some issues with the back ring for
whites
and we'll see Bishop B7 but then I take
ah there's that move
so I want to play with this move
[Music]
no okay I'm gonna Rook but
one engine blunder or didn't take it
foreign
I guess that's okay
oh no my Rook
I was trying to win
I mean I can't complain after such a a
bad position like I hung up on my my
Center was in shambles
I was not expecting that game to end in
stalemate
oh thank you premierco appreciate your
words
thanks for subbing
playing big pirate again
play this opponent once before
ah that was a scandi game I think
Maybe
it was one of the first games of the
tournament
uh
start with this
and then if F6 I take an H3
wow that doesn't really help though
he's still H3
take I take with Pawn
I'm almost dropping the knights
some weird tactics though
yeah there's that move
okay A bit more positional now
this could be very Raj
like I'm not sure how I actually fight
for a win
I guess I just try and gradually build
up on the king side
maybe you get in B5 unlucky
when it stops it
'd be five let's try to orchestrate B5
Mercure
no it doesn't work still
so the goal is to eventually play G4
well I have another idea too
unlock the king to B3
okay got in G4
if ever G5
not getting much
I want to play for a win
uh-oh
okay
looks a little bit stuck
how do I do this
let's get an F5 I guess
you're actually making progress it's
taking a while though
that's a good move
uh oh
all the pawns are falling
left right and Center
okay does that make me a bad person
I mean I really tried to like create
chances
and I got a dirty flag
and some type of position where like
there's a lot of ideas but it took a
while to actually play the ideas
uh
a couple of people asking for Zen mode
um maybe much later
still at the point where I've kind of
like to know who I'm playing
okay playing rain go
let's play this again
I've been having good success with the
Cambridge Springs
had this this is I think the third game
with uh this opening
and we had this line earlier in this E5
line
still following the game from earlier
so ideas I'm winning back the pawn
now earlier is a little bit different
because
I got some nice pressure on the D file
here I think I should Castle
I want to play C5 if I get the chance
okay this time light's controlling the D
file
maybe some eventual F4
oh that's a fork
there's this move though but then this
move
so the the pin would prevent me from
taking the Rook
oh there's this pin too wow
and so many pins
there there there
I mean this looks good
Force the bishop back to F1
I guess we just repeat
sort of takes I take on C3
it looks good now
it looks very good
yeah D2 oh there's Queen D4 though
um
might as well take
that's not so simple
I got too relaxed
what am I doing
I might be losing this
yeah this is not good
uh what to do
try this allow the queen
that's not good though
nice move
let's meet wow I'm just losing after
Queen A1 though
yeah I missed connects connect uh
connect five or connect six if you want
to count the queen
that was unfortunate had a really nice
position
[Music]
okay 50th place
um
yeah I haven't had much of a streak
since uh initial start of the tournament
rating has gone down 40 points
oh we have a Catalan
a new opening
I'm gonna play the Ray Robson variation
and trade lights for Bishops
foreign
trying to make progress
c3's idea
I think it's equal material but uh
a bit more pleasant for black
E4 cons oof
okay I can still tick with knights
and defend
so D5 Rook C5
okay this is a dream
white can shift over
venting rookie five
yeah at the right moment C3
take
okay now it's full domination
uh
Right Time Muscle stuff
holding onto the pond
I should still be winning I think
I'm going to take this
ooh
okay
and these games take work hey it's Ben
and Karen
what's up that in Karen
I appreciate the raid
shout out to Ben and Karen
if you're just joining this is uh the
spring Marathon
um I'm about two hours in
and
I'm top 50.
but been having some tough games so far
all right let's try and achieve some D4
I don't really want a queen trade
but maybe I do
I don't know what I want
all right let's take
I have a similar type of like grinding
position earlier
oh thanks to everyone like subbing and
resubbing
a lot of prime Subs
like four Prime Subs in a row
a friendly reminder if you have Amazon
Prime
subscribe for free
just like this Pawn
okay G5
uh
oh it feels so good
I play Rook D7 first
probably oh let's
let's make sure my bases are covered
so this one might happen
wow look at all these Prime Subs it's a
lot of Subs
thanks everyone
okay Knight D6 is probably gonna happen
now
but then Bishop B3
wow
okay
yeah free stuff is always very nice
thank you man a lot of people subbing
with prime for the first time
Frisk widow's Kimmer
tamalego bazic rarusi Jim Reiner
all right playing Dark gross
got a
got an early H5
um okay I'm playing a perverse crab
trying to pinch my opponent
oh
uh
I'm not sure how special this is
it looks special though
you might can no longer Castle kingside
okay more free stuff
can't complain
in G5
no need for G5
let's play this
and going after the C Pawn
there's Knight C4
oh there's a funny line
I should have played this first
I could have forced a triple Fork
okay it's Bobby Briggs gifting five
thank you Bobby
I do appreciate all the hype
okay and all the more free things
C3 I just take with the Knights
it's a fork but it's also like
Unstoppable discovery
okay that was pleasant
so I'm on a streak of some sort
okay muscle memory is taking over
playing on London
oh yes
uh what's Happening Here
Queen A3
so I'm pinning
defending against
scary things
not sure what just happened there
okay this is working out though
this is a pin
of my night getting trapped my Bishop's
getting trapped
but I win a pawn
wow wow
what is this game
what is this it's just Castle within
that nf2
oh no my Rook
wait what
was just happening
wait I'm down on time
no
my time dull my reading
oh it's so sad
oh I'm playing coach Raven shout out to
coach Raven but also sometimes streams
Oops I did not mean to play F6
but maybe it's Justified
okay so this is uh
probably not a great position for me but
it's playable
fancy
dull my thing
no I'm missing things
Let's Go full aggro now
okay that's a double attack
threatening made in one
somehow this is actually not so bad for
me
that's a great move
hmm
I don't know what's happening anymore
crazy crazy game
this should be good for me
oops
I don't know if it's good for me anymore
okay
that somehow turned out to be good for
me
oh dear
oh
top 30.
that was a crazy game
like at some point I blundered a piece
but then
uh it was kind of a Gambit and then I
don't know what happened
okay another bullet game
um
why I did that
uh
foreign
ah
a little bit slow what to do
a little bit too weak as well
as difficult position in the middle game
somehow I held on
it wasn't meant to be
33rd
we'll try and get to 100 points
playing a hub
another London
uh this is a fun one this is a reverse
Cambridge Springs
uh E6 is a move
there's a line here take take and then
Bishop A6 which is winning
here I think
wait what's the line here
take
huh
I forgot the line
try this
okay this is one idea just to expand on
the king's side
it's a fancy move
and I defend B2 from a distance
wait what
take
so I want a piece
uh I guess let's move
in Crazy position
[Music]
let's get out of there
the pieces are scattered
wow
should still be okay the pawns attack
three times
and that keeps me safe
I have 19 seconds
I have to make a loose first
there we go
okay
that wasn't easy oh man
oh
where am I the 31st Place
Stafford Gava time we had this line
earlier
this is a fun one
this is very fun
oh no White's Queen
okay I think I'm still undefeated with
the Stafford
a lot of quick wins with the sapphire
too
this is a fun line in the London
there's Knight C6 here Queen E8
let's start with this
I'm just pushing the H Pawn
yeah I'm okay with the trade of knights
the King on D2
actually if takes maybe bishop H6 first
Queen side Castle
uh take take
yeah this is a discovered attack
so up upon
life is pretty good
[Music]
that's a funny move
if takes takes the E5 square is cleared
for the queen
oh
kind of forgot about that
still looks good but
it's super simple
oh
it doesn't work though
Queen C7 Rook D7 takes Queen E5 F6 takes
the queen defends
uh
so G4
and still looks good
maybe you got Connect Four
[Music]
um
take take 25
Block's gonna be stuck
like after Queen on Fates
king of it
wait a minute
friends first preventing Queen D3
it might not be the best technique
it should be winning though
oops
okay now it's just a mess
though I allowed perpetual
no
oh wow
opponent doesn't go for it
it's a risk
okay
that was a weird King Pawn ending man
well I could have forced to draw but
yeah the the bad decision led to a
better story I guess
or it was a good decision to play for
win just
yeah not enough time for black
okay uh berserk back E4
so top 20 oh no my Pawn
okay I'm going full Gambit mode
the more pawns I lose the more open
files I gain
opponent maybe has the same philosophy
oops I'm getting forked
ah
okay
let me try and get some compensation
here
the more pieces I lose
the last pieces I have to blunder
always have to look on the right side
hitting this Pawn
and this Pawn
okay should be winning now
okay that was a weird game
17th Place
so I have 96 points leader has 164. wow
okay let's try and get revenge on this
opponent
lost to them earlier
okay this is a nice trap
okay 13 move win
That's a classic track for that opening
12th Place
past 100 points
uh no berserking play D4
trying to be tricky with the move order
got the bishop here
probably not anything too special for
whites
uh
yeah the Block's probably slightly for
choice
but this is a classic structure
we're gonna five
okay going for chibos
um
yeah the cheapos don't work
how's my queen doing
foreign
very passive
what else to do
it was actually a very difficult
position about explaining this well
I'm trying to hold on
I don't think it's losing Kingdom ending
you're barely holding on
really
might be winning now
this is winning
okay
man I was getting tortured for most of
that game I got a very passive position
somehow kept surviving and
like the king pong ending I think my
opponent just over pushed
11th Place
uh okay
never played this opponent before
Sicilian time
yeah so this is a typical maneuver
oh I should have taken the bishop we
were both moving too quickly there
oh what to do
I have to slow down a little bit
really
a lot of trains there
not the move I wanted to play
but I hold on to the extra Pawn
eventually I want to get in B4 and
Bishop C2
really
Queen E5
huh
uh what to do
foreign
way too much time
let's go okay
just enough time there
oh man
yeah I think opponent was going like
playing too much on the clock and
probably could have gradually flagged me
okay I have a long winning streak
uh I've played 43 games so far
playing Soul tie again
mix up the opening a little bit
and time on of time
d695
yeah trading a bit
or not
[Music]
no draw
F6 is questionable
it's interesting though
I didn't see five oh I'm in trouble
yeah this is a big trouble
there there
try something
good game ah what to do
yeah F6 was probably a very questionable
move
okay what's the best way to untilt
oh this is not quite a Stafford although
maybe it will resemble a Stafford
or maybe that's just a kind of an equal
middle game
I don't mind this like Bishop G4
reminds me of a marshall
threatening to trap the queen
there's some F5
actually don't see how to
maximize Advantage here
it should be good but
take some patience
actually this is pretty good
that pawn should fall
um
[Music]
still not simple
you know why I went for this
H6
maybe this is why
so
I'm winning dock upon
up two pawns now
okay
so this little oh
I was about to say this will be an
instructive end game how to win with G
and H Pawn but I guess we won't see it
somewhere on YouTube I have a endgame
lecture showing how to win that position
okay this is a fun line E4
so opening up the position
having the bishop hair
uh there is Queen E5 defending both
Pawns
okay this should be very good now
Bishop E3
I'll just develop
taking almost works
let's keep the bishop pair
I'm dreaming of some tactics
oh my knight
Salman Khan ambulance
oh but actually my knight
G5
I have this move though
what's happening
so both Queens are hanging like Queen
defends a bishop
takes takes is probably a good trade for
me if the queen Retreats I take here and
there's a pin
so I think this is okay
oh Queen E7
okay Life Goes On
a nice time advantage
I think my opponent Burns a lot of time
earlier
trying to navigate through the chaos
I'm gonna take on the A7
start with this
not sure what H4 was
but I made Luft
okay
I think at some point I'm gonna take a
break maybe even end the Stream
um
because it's past dinner time
and it's been a while since I've had
food
Bishop A3
wow
the new opening
just trying to play solidly here
follow some principles
the guy hung upon
uh
take take
oh it's just a trade it takes life work
that's fortunate
maybe threatening this
just be solid first
so I'm hitting the Knight
almost trapping the knights
Knights are very tricky
I think I want to take and then take
if I get the chance
I can find this and this
okay
that was a tricky game
I'm top 10.
Life Goes On
tonight C3
it's a fun line this is a very tricky
line of jobava London
I mean black could transpose into some
main lines there's Knight C6
whose takes
yeah so there's a line takes takes takes
takes
E5
I feel like I've encountered this before
like Bishop B5
I mean visually it looks very nice
I am not sure what black does here
there's two big threats if takes takes I
win material
uh thank you earlier to markadarka donk
well it's key seven
um if I take
and then here
King F6 may be coming
wait what's happening
Queen side Castle
and just giving away The Rook
although Bishop G2 Knight F3
takes her Rook it's made in two
this is a fun decision
sometime
Checkmate in one
that's also uh what quadruple Fork
okay that was a very pleasant opening
oh playing Soul tie again
do I berserk how berserk but what
opening do I play
play D6
going through all my Sicilian lines
oh this one
it's a tricky move order
maybe losing a pawn
I lost upon
but treating it as a gamut
I have to be really really careful
at this move
so why can't Castle the one side
Castle's other side
take take
I know what's happening anymore
[Music]
half pawns defended from a distance
foreign
okay
why why go for a technique when you can
Spike check
oh man
hey it's Nate Brady appreciate the rain
hope you had a good stream
if you're just joining I think this was
my longest game
101 moves
oh
all right crossed some number
isn't there some move cap on like games
you can request analysis on
are you not feeling well
I'm a little bit under the weather I
mentioned this at the very beginning of
the Stream
I don't know if people can tell
based on my voice
100 accuracy
it was very short-lived maybe towards
the end of the game though
99 accuracy
oh it's so funny because oh wait no
82 percent
I thought because it's such a long game
it just increases accuracy but
not quite
okay
top ten
oh
playing a high rated player
play some qgd
exchange variation
earlier my opponent fell for this trap
this time it's not happening
usually the Queen's on C2 by now
I guess White's managed to not have to
play A3
does usually played in these lines
yeah F4 is a good move
um I get away with sacking probably not
yeah this is where I just hunkered down
and go for some gradual expansion
White's played the opening well
because Knight should be on D6
if I play
94 we trade
doesn't work
G4 is a terrifying move
I guess I'll play this
really hunkering down
King h8 I'd get mated
wow
what play from light
so I don't want to open the file I guess
I played this
scary position Queen F5 might be coming
or that move wow
yeah Queen F5 is coming soon
there's a force meat though I block on
F6
that's a good move I have this move ah
Queen G8
yeah I'm getting torn apart
uh okay
King will go for a stroll
trying to find some shelter
not the best shelter though
oh he's played this really well
I'm not even taking the pawn
[Music]
hey it's a skewer
I feel accomplished
wow
I don't feel so accomplished
I have so little time
oh no my king
yeah well you played really well in that
game
did I stand a chance
what was my Improvement
you can see two F4
F4 is a good move
yeah Queen F5 first would have been more
destructive
but yeah the whole game white was in
control
[Music]
okay still top ten
um
I want to eat soon so
I think what I'll do is
if I lose a game I end the Stream
because I'm hungry
so if I keep winning I guess I keep
streaming
this is a fun line
a nice London trap
thank you suds
okay not ending the stream after that
one
still in eighth place
thank you it's a rock fact
s earlier to Gaston LV
17. oh I'm playing the same opponent
okay let's try and get revenge if I lose
I end this stream
uh let's play this line
okay
E4 yeah this is some theory that I
forget
I Bishop D7
I may have already gone wrong like this
might be completely fine for black
and just try and develop
keeping some time Edge
hmm
maybe threatening this
wow
I'm getting on Play It Again
take
uh it doesn't work
I have a desperate move
logical move
really
I blundered
maybe some comp
no no comp
uh what to do
if takes with stalemate oh no it's not
stalemate
oh
so it's Checkmate okay
oh no my stream
okay it's time for dinner
uh thanks everyone for watching
made it almost almost three hours
I'm I'm pausing not gonna retire from
the entire tournament
and just a brief pause
uh I imagine when I come back
I'll be out of top ten
okay so I've
what did I do I streamed about three
hours of this tournament when it first
began
um if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
it's very possible I'll be combining the
first part and this part into a single a
singular video
and the the entire video might be close
to 12 hours I think YouTube has an
upload limit of 12 hours
but I do plan to play
about the remaining nine hours
so
we'll see what happens
when I pause a tournament
about what 10 hours ago 11 hours ago
uh I was in the top ten now I'm I'm
still in the top 900.
so maybe about like half hour or two
hour in
I'll run a prediction
of what place I might finish
but yeah I paused with 135 points
currently the leader has 780 points
so I have some work to do but top 10
still less than 500 so
I got 135 points over the course of like
just under three hours
so if I do the math nine hours
maybe 500 tournament points would be a
reasonable goal
um I am a little bit under the weather I
have some kind of mix of like a cold and
allergies so at some point I might talk
less but I'm still alive and that's what
matters I have some tea I also have some
water
so okay no more wasting time
that's hot in
and here we go playing alakyne Fisher
uh staff for Gambit time
still offering
okay we'll have some sort of like
symmetrical Italian
so after D3 I like to play G5
and just go full attack
because inclusion of H3 makes it
much easier to open the file
the use can mean
so essentially white has to allow the
bishop to come in or have to move the
knights
now Knight T4 is a massive threat
yeah life is pretty good here
in Queen E3 I could take but I think
after Queen E3 Knight H5 is a bit
stronger
just setting up this and this
no mercy
I think this goes to show the power of
the early like G5 G4
there is no need to Castle
so if Rook G1
I could start with the queen H4 but
maybe even better to take here first
actually no Queen H4 or G8 take and then
Fork in the end
so here here
here here
takes takes fork and then win the queen
okay 13 move win
to start the beginning of the finale
in my previous game I did lose
previous stream ended with uh if I lose
a game I end the Stream
thank you Fang Duster
trying to create a hype train
welcome back to ponziani scheme
I'll play the same opening
so this time we might transpose into
Stafford
and we do
I had a couple games yesterday with
Bishop
uh Bishop C4
so with this line
going for Knight G4
H file is now open
d4s may be coming you can play this
though
Knight G3 Queen H7 maybe still Queen H7
so Bishop Ford defending Bishop D6
attacking
foreign
oh no my Bishop
I'm trying to figure out the
final blow here
not sure if this works actually white
could take
looks dangerous though
I think after it takes I play Queen E4
F3
take take and then Queen g2's a main
threat
okay threatening three different things
thank you stockfish thank you Fame
Duster
we officially have a hype train
okay 16 move win no mercy
a couple fun similar openings from the
back pieces
like very aggressive openings
all right let's play Knight C3
from Bishop B5
I don't think I played the sign yet this
tournaments just a Grand Prix attack
Queenie one
okay trying to lock down the queen side
first
hmm
some tension
okay now I'm feeling very good and two
different pawns attacked
uh I might as well take
so Queen takes I play Bishop E3
yeah no mercy here
when the night moves I take and the
Knight F6 comes
like really no mercy
uh
there's this funny move
attacking the Knight and Pawn
so I'm up three pawns and the exchange
okay
my longest game thus far this stream
that was pleasant though
playing ion Ahmed
uh we'll play E4 again
welcome back to CDR Siri
happy 20 months subbing a tier two
okay we'll play the setup with Queen F3
yeah Bishop C5 is just losing a tempo
Bishop D7
it's a strange move
because usually the Knight likes to come
into play
all right so I'm trying to set up a
queen trap like Bishop G5 is now a major
threat
oh no blocks Queen
yeah a lot of people would automatically
take the bishop but
Queen is more valuable
thank you phyla thank you Benji chess
I do appreciate the resubs
I have a mute a mutes learned I I have
alerts muted just to try and stay more
focused
um so I might miss various alerts but I
do appreciate the support
okay sagging upon
at Bishop B2 I play Rook B1 and win the
pawn back
or not pleasant for black
just want to check needs G6 I take the
bishop
okay the pawn can't be defended
hitting this bishop
open the H file
try and swing the queen in
or the rook in
okay
maybe one goal is to get back to the
2800 rating
um not too far away
have a lot of goals here
thank you Mama Dev a first time Prime
sub
okay Stafford Canada time
I'm still undefeated with Stafford this
tournament
as far as I know so the third time this
tournament uh I was playing Bishop C4
and the the two previous games and this
game all featuring the same line
yeah this is double check
no mercy here
I'll have to make a compilation of like
all these staffer games
it's been
it's been at least like five so far
three from that line a few more from a
different line
but
I think still showing to Be an Effective
opening especially at this time control
okay playing Tony realist it's berserk I
want it to berserk okay
uh time odds I guess I'll I'll take it
I feel a little bit bad
can I sack
Knight F7 Queen H5
uh
maybe not let's just play solidly
preventing Bishop G4
I'm playing like very prophylactically
the early h3a3
that move I forgot about
life is pretty good here
solid setup
at the Rooks in
made into
the problem for black is this bishop
and black would like to do this stuff
still controlling space
oh
What's Happening Here
oh no locks Queen
got some fun pawns okay I feel a little
bit bad I didn't berserk
generally if the opponent of the zerks
I'll berserk back
I guess I should hit the berserk button
before playing the first move
there's not too many usernames that are
four characters long
also this is my first
time encountering the Polish this
tournament
F4 F4 take
I actually don't know the theory though
they'll just be safe
wait Queen here here
's another three
let's do it let's have some fun
there's a funny line
uh Knight of three
so I'll play F6
okay never mind
I was imagining like my queen would come
to E3 and exploit the PIN
okay preventing light from castling
interesting position
so now I'm threatening this
a lot of pins in this position
pawns pinned this Pawn was pinned
the night was supposed to be pinned but
it moved
so what's happening
I think I can take
and then take
I think I'm winning a pawn here
unless Bishop takes
no then I installing upon
so the point is after takes takes a rook
defends a bishop
oh
okay I still want to pawn to the sign
and just leave the bishop chilling
play this move
I should not have put my Knights
in such a square it really should have
gone here to support the other night
foreign
I have to sneeze
I've gone all this time without sneezing
and this position is really nothing to
sneeze at
and try and hold off might be winning
another Pawn
there's takes ooh
uh
okay let's bring the Knight to D6
so two Bishops against two knights
Knights are actually pretty well
coordinated
Knight C4
approaching the time scramble
it feels close to meat
huh
foreign
I'll take it
welcome back to munchie
yeah I will be posting more on the extra
Channel
kind of got behind with all the travels
but so a lot of streams in the pipeline
uh play E4
it's been my go-to opening against
Carroll Khan lately a two nights attack
D4 here
or no the sign Bishop Z5 Rook D1
okay I'll go for F5
yeah the Bishops generally like the more
open positions
on how to do this
so I chased away The Rook from defending
F7 and now
I consume F7
and Black's in big trouble but how do I
mate
I'm threatening made in one
and not immediately winning
I might just trade trade everything
and take take
Bishop G6 doesn't really do anything
[Music]
okay I'll trade down
so up upon
now I have two Pawns
be careful
on the play H4
foreign
there is no Fork
okay
that took some work
required some just patience and end game
technique
uh but we move on
top 700 top 650.
okay this is a new territory
white someone gambiting here
I don't think I'm getting punished
foreign
so this is a threat
but this should be okay
oh
just preventing Knight C3
and Rook B1 is coming
okay I want to take the Knight
but I want to lose a bishop
or okay one's coming
okay when I take the knights
okay this should be fine now
that was very fine
hmm
okay
so staying clean the street
trying to break into the top 600.
maybe after this game I'll I'll start
the prediction
[Music]
um
just so people can major their Channel
points
guess which place I'll finish in
I think this is the first D4 game on
this stream
there's been a lot of E4 today
okay Cambridge Springs time
this can be a tricky line if white
doesn't know what they're doing
it's one of the better lines though if
white doesn't know what they're doing
I think H6 is
like H6 and castling
like eventually C5
I'm actually forgetting the theory here
odd some B6 move too
maybe I start with taking
remember one of the main ideas is to
trade off
my worst Bishop for White's best Bishop
there's actually a game that dingler and
played this opening is black
and beat pragandanda
like really nice positional game
it featured some similar structure
uh
okay we'll keep Trading
and queen C4
preventing Pawn C4
okay that's a move
wait a minute let's not hang a bishop
uh
I've changed my mind
a little bit passive but still solid
up some time
I don't mind this
oh
wait how the chance sir
I want to do the the caterpillar
I contract
and then expand
I could have probably taken the pawn
okay
so on a nice streak
have not been berserking but
maybe that's been a good strategy
you your brother
things earlier to Trevi
uh playing Dennis 44
oh I forgot to run the prediction after
this game staff again the time no
Queen E7 I don't think is a main line
Castle
okay blacks
I think mindlessly pre-moving
now maybe suffering the consequences
teotaki asking who I'm rooting for in
the world championship
if I had to choose probably ding but
nepo's a friendly person
[Music]
it's it's hard to pick a favorite
actually
but it's been a fun match to watch so
far
okay so C5 is pretty much forced
a Bishop's coming here
and that should be lights out for black
Queen B5 is
very hard to stop
okay let me take a small break and I
actually already have the prediction set
up
um hopefully this makes sense
so I do plan to try and play the rest of
the tournament
um let me pause for a moment
so there's about eight and a half hours
left
um
and people can choose between five
options
I'm currently in
just within the top 600
so I think these are fair options
um this will be a half hour prediction
so people can
be patient
you can measure your your points right
away
but the prediction won't be awarded
until after the tournaments
and just to show
um wait how many turn points I have 175
um
top 10
is over 500.
top 30.
yeah I'm about 200 points away from Top
30.
so I should be able to like pass 400
tournament points by the end of the
tournament but
people are also going to be rising so
it might be hard to to cage we're all
finished
thank you Purple Penguin first time
probably
[Music]
I know someone was asking about
whether I can play some tunes
generally I put these Marathon streams
on YouTube and then there's all these
issues with uh
like copyrights
but I did actually so recently I signed
up for this site
it's called epic epidemic sounds
and uh it gives me access to a lot of
like copyright free
Tunes maybe at some point I'll
experiment with
but it should really be based off chat
feedback like if
majority of people want tunes and chats
then uh maybe I'll listen
okay we have a Blackboard Deemer
so this is the line I like to play
against BlackMart gamer
giving back the pawn but after takes
uh this Pawn's a bit weak
wait I could have taken this Pawn though
I think I already messed this up oops
yeah I messed us up
I'm gonna be down upon
I got confused
on the bright side of this Pawn is
a little bit weak
oh no my Pawn
okay this is getting interesting now I
think I'm trapping the bishop
yeah White's a little bit slow with
like the typical A4 A5 break
let's pin the knights
thank you wild basics
I could take your first
might as well
just trying to make sure white doesn't
have any compensation
the bishop's still trapped
it takes I'd probably take with knights
oh no my other Pawn
that pawn was probably free
okay Bishop T5
oops
what did I just do
I was a little bit careless
should still be okay but
uh wasn't necessary
okay timely resignation
okay still undefeated this stream
I'm playing Felipe
played once before
I think we played maybe last night
or no
I played Felipe when they were rated
1475.
is this my first D4 of
the stream it might be
London time
I have to sneeze
excuse me
man this position is still nothing to
sneeze at
thank you chat for blessing me
and saluting me
wow
no mercy here
want to play Rook D7
yeah Doc's using some initiative
so I'm up a full Queen and
plenty of Pawns
yeah it was worth giving away The Rook
for Bishop
lost Defenders for the Locking
okay
here we go
um go back to E4
this is a very positional approach
okay this is also a very typical tactic
latex G5
Queen's undefended and if takes I take
your first with check
yeah this Pawn should fall eventually
I see a request for two nights Tango
I could I don't think I played that yet
this tournament
oh boy
and these dark swears
so juicy
I think I just take on F7
and win like all the pawns and mate
actually
I have no need to take any Pawns
okay
uh moving on
okay if D4 lights Tango
if E4
[Music]
staff or Gambit time
okay Italian time
I'm cure Bishop G4
I'm just going over the classic Knight
T4
I'll get the bishop hair
I think I missed a chance to take the
knights
I'm delaying castling
it's taking actually work
I'm a little bit too curious
because I'm threatening this
okay this works
after the game I want to check with
engine though
uh
H5
okay I'll just trade
I'll play this first
yeah there's many times where these
socks on each three are like very
dubious
uh real quick
I should have taken here
Mr chance
although it's probably not that bad for
whites maybe it is bad
okay so the engine would defend this
but only move d4
which makes sense just blocking the
bishop
am I queen and I can only do so much
okay
back to tournament
question from cloud blood good
have you ever gotten been so badly by an
opening that you started playing that
opening yourself
I can think of at least one example
um
when I was younger like rated around
I lost a really one-sided game
to the schliemen of the Spanish like
Bishop B5 and F5
oh okay we have the sign
uh let me try and remember my theory
this is a vukovich Gambit
this is a move
probably a few moves there though
supposed to take
it's been a while since I looked at the
theory here
yeah this is terrifying
I'm up two pieces though
interesting
this is the sharpest line in ponziani I
think it's almost refutation of the
ponziani
that uh
trying to hold on
Knight to cover his D2 thankfully
thank you
I'm still up two pieces or two Palms
things like Knight C4 Queen B5 B3 should
be a solid Construction
five might be coming
ooh
wow
very tricky
I think everything's okay
up a lot of material now
a rook and knights
okay
yeah that was a
that was a tricky game
generally this opening it's
it's one of these things like
it's terrifying but if white doesn't get
mated and holds onto material
then white should be better
but there's a lot of theory that I think
we both forgot
so I gained a rating point for that game
top 500
keep moving on
yeah this is already Pleasant
here I've trapped the bishop
ooh
why he wants to try my Bishop
you just want to win the pawn
and maybe later again in Knight F3
I have three runs into Queen E3
foreign
although where's my
I guess I just win the night
covering G7
foreign
okay
um I'm gonna take a small break and I'll
be right back
I'm back I got some uh
one of these like lasange things
hopefully we'll soothe the throat a
little bit
there was a sub from Anjali
how do you manage the figure of yourself
after a massive an important blunder
I kind of struggle with this and it
makes me not want to play chess much
anymore
yeah the thing thing to realize is
blundering is part of the game like if
you play enough chess it's gonna happen
of course you want to like minimize it
as much as possible
I talk a little bit about how to deal
with it in
my round two recap from Reykjavik
it was a video titled chassis stressful
it was a game that I was like crashing a
GM I had multiple like easy wins I miss
um I ended up losing
and
it's so important to just take away
lessons from every game and kind of
shifts the mindset uh just keep learning
and enjoying
enjoying playing
and ultimately like that mindset will
probably help you reach your full
potential
rather than just focusing on like
winning or rating
okay back to tournaments
almost 200 terminal points
uh
playing Resident douche
should I keep pentatonic I'll keep
pentatonic for one game
I mean um because I'm gonna consume this
uh cough drop thing
so I might uh not talk as much
let me put the mic further away so you
don't hear like um
oh
foreign
[Music]
let me turn off pentatonic
I was in control most of that game and I
plungered a piece but
still had enough time
that determent
hello to Brad
I slept like so so
um
yeah like not not my best sleep but
that's okay I got a few hours worth
oh hello to everyone named Brad
gotta be at least a few Brads watching
okay let's Castle
let me go for E5
yeah an event of takes takes the knights
pinned to the pawn
Knight G4 I probably play Bishop B5
Chuck
maybe this so
it looks like I'm losing a pawn but I'm
not because of Bishops tied down to
defending the knights
huh
okay so takes takes takes there's
division E5
I think you real life actuary
another first time Prime
okay smooth game
foreign
I've lost track of how many games in a
row I've won but still undefeated the
Stream
oh thank you earlier to ipala and cola
mix
I appreciate the subs
and Onyx a dog
okay I'm not gonna suck on each three
especially after King H2 but I'll still
go for this uh kingside attack
which is my heart rate monitor just stop
updating
and got disconnected sorry about that
or maybe I've been consistently beating
at 91 beats per minute
hmm
I want to play G3
let's play G3
so it's more of a long-term positional
sacrifice
ponds are doubled
would be
like steady pressure on the G file
okay
led to a quick tactic there
because if we got to a situation where I
allow white to play G3 then I can't
access the square
so it's basically removing the pawn so I
have use of the square and the file
and they pay off
okay all berserk I think this is the
first double berserk game in the Stream
uh Latvian gambits let's play this
I'm out of any sort of prep
I don't know what I've done here
shouldn't be too bad though
or is it
foreign
oh I think I've reached a peak heart
rate for this stream
oh okay
hey it's hashtag chess reading in a nice
time shout out to hashtag chess
I appreciate the rain
have to cool down after that one
thank you Erica Amy
let me uh let me actually check the
opening
because this is a lafian Gambit
but with Knight C6
it's like um
a lot viewing combined with a Stafford
oh just Queen H5 here
Queen H5 how does this work G6 take
maybe it's a little bit tricky though
Rook G8 it's actually like an
interesting
variation
I'm probably still worth calling into is
white
okay back to tournaments if you're just
joining this is a spring Marathon
I have not streamed the whole thing but
uh or about
hour and 15 minutes into the Stream
uh there was a request earlier for
knight's Tango but can only play Knights
Tango after C4 and move two
so we have one of these
like a Torre attack
resembles a London though
yeah this is already pretty Pleasant
a very typical idea
and now the plan is to just go after the
G3 Pawn
not super easy to defend his white
I guess Knight F1 will come
but still a very pleasant position
so if I take
I feel like I'm spoiled for Choice F5
looks interesting
so now that our file's open
gee G4 the problem for white is there's
some eventual pin
or eventual Fork
okay
Pleasant game
still working my way up
playing Georgie
this is a tricky line Bishop C4
opponent doesn't know it
I think I'll take and then 95
simplify a little bit
this light's a little bit weirdly placed
okay now it's happily placed
a very happily placed
so E5 Queen D4 check
he's still Queen D4
and rookie next
Pawn should fall
it's falling down the board
East Africa
there is Knight E4 here
we trade a little bit
okay let's take
and wow what a move
oh no my queen
okay
yeah I know D3 was hanging earlier I
probably could have taken it I was more
interested in winning the epon
okay top 400.
I still have my original tea from
while I brewed before the Stream
Queen C7
what do they call this like the rats
it is a kind of solid setup for Black
but white should be happy
I think I just forgot about this Pawn
oops
black also forgot about the pawn
I'm just a blind spot on A5
I mean I forgot the pawn was hanging but
my opponent forgot the pawn could take
diagonally
okay up a piece here
going after B6
thank you forcing gay tricks
uh oh
I did have Rook E3 so it wasn't that bad
I just have to always be careful with
the queen in King of lines
some idea Rook A7
Mickey tricky
wait why did I do that
okay I'm losing that material
I forgot my night was pinned if I took
I'd get pinned
and lose a queen
but I'm up uh
I'm still on material
oh
even after Bishop E3
up enough
foreign
again I'm not feeling 100 but uh still
trying to power through
um
still on the streak
if anyone wants to count and tell me how
many teams I've won in a row that would
be nice
but we keep going
we'll play E4
I'll play a two nights attack
transposing into Rubenstein
Bishop D4 this is generally a pleasant
already threatening to take and take
the other way with taken take
let's try it it's risky
I have not like calculated fully
uh let's meet in a few I think
I think King G8 was best I think it was
just winning for black
although I'm not sure
wait let me analyze
okay I got the quick win
but
after
yeah after King G8 oh this has been
played before
oh White's doing okay
ah because Queen F4 Queen F5 I win the
bishop
apparently Rook ft and I don't have a
win
okay it paid off
I think you remove happy eight months
so top 350
the win streak continues
so this is some kind of like Rivers
London
okay comfy position pieces are happy
um
yeah this move
threatening made into
okay
a nice little tactic
What place would you like to finish in
I mean first place would be nice but I'm
kind of far away from that
I have 236 turbo points
first has just under 900
okay ponziani time
oh the prediction is over
we did have a half hour long prediction
of
what place people are
guessing I'll finish
I think most people voted for like
between 50 and 100.
which I think is reasonable
can I take
I really want to take I mean Knight G5
is
perhaps a little bit more controlled
but this is a little bit more fun
not a typical tactic like this is
similar to a Greek gift
but mainly exploiting the fact that this
Pawn is uh undefended
okay a quick win
having a good number of Quick wins today
playing classic
wait Daniel fired shots at ponziani
Daniel played the ponziani and U.S
championships
he drew like an almost super GM
but it is an opening with maybe some
limitations
good very high levels of box prepared
it can be a little bit uncomfortable for
whites
but at lower levels it's I think a great
great beginner opening
okay so this is a Ray Robinson variation
of the Catalan
um
kind of an obscure line I'm losing back
upon well I can take twice if white
takes here I take on D4
I did have this line once last night
the first part of the tournament that I
streamed
we have a very similar position to
so it's equal material the black should
be for choice
E4 might be coming
so I'm trying to discourage E4 by
targeting the d-pawn
no more back rank issues
some idea of playing C3
okay now that you Pawn is backwards
half open file
but how does it make progress
hmm
probably not the best approach there
oh
it's going to be a time scramble
I think I'm winning now
okay that took some work
took a lot of work
um getting a rating point for that
I'll take it
trying to climb into the top 300.
7 hours and 41 minutes to go
playing mcangel
okay this is a barbin variation
[Music]
um the E3 I think A6
and then B6
essentially getting a pleasant setup
so I can see the bishop here
I'm not sure if the Knight belongs
on e4
and maybe it's okay
let's try it I might regret this
it was very closely getting traps but F3
okay those are almost Free Pawn
C7 hangs
and then Knight G5
we're both trying to attack on the king
side
okay Knight H3
like almost Force mate
if takes it's made in two
oh uh Queen G4 is not made into
now it's mates
okay
yeah position got weird I don't think 95
is supposed to be good
let me check it though
so I'm not supposed to take
just continue with developing okay
okay
um E4
question from baby Yoda how many chess
books have you read so far
when growing up I had probably a few
dozen chess books in my my household
but I think it was pretty rare that I
would finish a single book
but I read bits and pieces of a lot of
different books
kind of based on what I wanted to learn
whether it's tactics or
strategy you're going through like high
level games
I have a very similar position earlier
like almost exact same position I went
for the Greek gift
um this time I'll be a little bit more
cautious
although here
yeah here I don't think it works
but we'll still be aggressive
foreign
it's too interesting to pass up
so after takes takes Rook of Southern's
Forest
and then Bishop G6
okay this is an eight and two
yeah these attacks are like so vicious
from the
um from this opening
is very dangerous opening to play in in
Blitz
maybe the sacrifice was dubious but
okay I worked out
berserking
so we have a bullet game
somehow I'm winning a piece here
even though white was more active
I still have to be careful though
oh
I'll check with King
I know let's take with rook and then win
F2
still have to be careful
and just be extra safe
oh
this should be okay I think
so I'm hitting the queen and threatening
mates
got a little bit tricky there
yeah
yeah there's no no mating idea D is
covered by The Rook
okay
so the win streak continues
that 31 wins in a row wow
playing the zlog name full Bill gator
oh I forgot to play Knights Tango
sorry to the person who's been waiting
for me to play that
okay this is a fun one
I'm getting a lot of like quick traps
today
oh it's so pleasant
hey it's John what's up John
asking about bungee jumping
I don't think I've ever been bungee
jumping in my life
maybe someday
all right so I'm up upon
still takes a bit of work to convert
um take with Queen
oh
okay I can take on F2
but with a wallet and Bishop
E3 will fall
okay the queen just wants to come to H2
Pawn wants to come to E3
so here here
not immediately winning
thankfully my queen was not trapped
what is this position
or the Kings on G4
threatening some Rook F4 now
um
it takes a lot of work
objectively box should be better because
pawns are weak
I'm down on time
yeah all I need to do is
win me too
some really loud thunder outside
okay that took work
oh man okay
it continues
yeah I think it's been a good choice to
not berserk
playing an ortho shotgabit now
it's gonna be a risky opening to play
sometimes
the opponent's handling this well
or are they
seven
looks good for light
I can take on
wait what's Happening Here
I think I'll take your first
and then 97.
oh that's a move
I'm probably not better here
but it's equal material
okay I'll make an outpost
um
and box played as well so far
's a little bit weak
foreign
oh wow
does this work
it might be okay for me
yeah this is working out
Dole
is it still working out
Maybe
foreign
there we go
okay that was a tough game probably my
toughest game so far this stream
I was really really close
okay I gained a reading point for that
opponent played really well though
neutralize the ortho schnapp
okay we have a knight's Tango my first
night's Tango
D5 is generally not supposed to be great
but okay if I take I lose a thing
there's reminiscent of an alkyne I think
white could play the four pawns attack
I think I'd like to get the bishop here
I'm gonna go for this attack
[Music]
um
never mind
uh maybe you still do something
like Bishop F2 Queen H3
wow
if I take
so Bishop f2i Bishop takes F3
thank you Panther
appreciate the first time Prime
oh yeah somehow we traded off a lot and
I'm up two Pawns
yeah this Pawn is backwards
ideas to attack it with everything
can't quite Win It
I can win B2
play B6 first
just ensuring there's no counter play
and light has a lot of outpost squares
what's my plan to make progress I guess
I'll win on time
or B4 is one idea
C6
okay
although win streak continues
top 250.
we'll play E4
let's play a new opening G3
it's like a weird version of uh Kings a
new attack
C3
okay eventually I'd like to play B4
G5 is probably coming
and preventing the four getting the file
some Queen A7 maybe I should have
considered
like Queen A7 here
threatening made in one
not so easy for black
uh that's a good move
take
yeah D3 is hanging
I think this is okay
it might not be okay Knight C6 here here
Rook B8
uh
okay this should be fine though
but still tricky
so I'm down the exchange
this is not good for me
like holding on for dear life now
some Rook B7
okay that was a miss
finding this now
there we go
very tricky game
okay
welcome back to cool grapes happy 22 and
mapper
the 18.
almost lost my streak there that was a
close one
all right let's play this
I could take
taking Queen A4
some potential targets here
excuse me
uh this position is nothing to sneeze at
almost every position is nothing disease
at
thanks again for blessing me
I feel so blessed
so how to do this I guess this move
threatening Rook B8
foreign
that puts me at
277 tournament points
uh
trying to approach the top 200.
let's just see my stats real quick
85 win rates
um see I did lose some games in my
previous stream
average a point rating 2251 performance
rating is less than my current rating
it's trying to climb back to 2800
and yeah if you're just joining the
stream this is a 24-hour long tournament
I played the first like about three
hours that I slept and I'm back for
hopefully the remaining hours
playing handle X
uh I'll play D5
I'll go back to the usual
London opening
haven't actually faced too many londons
foreign
H5
[Music]
haven't seen that H4 before
allowing this
I think it's okay though five
because if H5 Queens like castling
it gets weird
Bishop D3
a very strange position
should be good for luck
take
I mean might as well try and open the
center
Queen A5
like White's pieces are all kind of
stuck
The Rook can't move visual can't move
Knights pins to The Rook
it's a full party on the queen side
I even have this move
wow so take says this move
I assume that's working
although I'm not sure
this should be working King D1
[Music]
oh
oh wow everything's hanging
The Rook still attacked but the king's
in trouble
what a funny game
wow I'm down upon
my position still looks good
now it's equal material
now I'm up upon
up on time too
okay that was a cool game
oh I have a new another tab open so
another game just started
okay let me turn off pentatonic
so I think it slows me down a little bit
we'll play D5
no London we have uh benoni
that's typical idea in 1985
I think I'd like to get this set up
Queen on F2
have this battery
feels like a standstill on on the queen
side
box is moving back and forth
maybe this idea
something gradually improving
I'm gaining time too
hmm
foreign
there
everything's still controlled
okay pretty solid game
a lot of maneuvering in the whole game
uh gained two reading points for that
thank you Jarl Carl
five months
okay I think this is my highest rated
opponents
so far this stream
or maybe not maybe I'd not sure though
okay let's play B5
yeah this is a case where I just try and
hold on to the pawn
it gets weird though
White's gonna try and poke in prod
I've lost track of my streak if someone
wants to like count the number of games
I've won
uh feel free to do so
take care
C6 is defended
yeah so that was another Free Pawn
oops
um
it was not a good move
should still be okay but
not something to allow
okay I'm still up a pawn
before maybe coming next
97.
it's a knight's pinned kind of
wow
Rook C7
okay I think everything's okay
thank you Thomas Martin Knight happy 26
months
foreign
[Music]
still not trivial
oh
foreign
tricky ending almost let it slip
okay
let me keep it going
I'll play E4
been playing a lot more E4 today
I'm playing the Four Knights E3
A5 wow
wait does this work
so with A5 included
I think it's just a better version
hmm
but how does it go
there there
this first
a confusing position
[Music]
Queen side casting is probably a move
yeah we're trading a lot
this move first
and then if I take
it's still just a fair trade
there's a trick though like Queen D5
take take Bishop G7
so Queen D6 is probably necessary
a very confusing situation though
uh you know this move
no draw
I'm okay going into this ending because
Fox pawns are a bit fixed on
dark squares
ah okay I have this move
there's almost solve Knox problems
it's much easier to play this for white
as this Pawn gets fixed
objectively it still might be a draw but
okay maybe this
yeah I got the outside passer
okay
this is interesting end game weird
opening though
I'm curious after Bishop D7 what's
White's best move
castling
I'm supposed to take first on C6
okay
hey it's Pam welcome back happy 32
months
a fox
a fox says my streak so far is 39 wow
okay I'll try and keep it up
um let's play a wing Gambit how about
haven't played this yet
so I'm down the pawn but there's less
pressure on the center
I think I can trade off the Bishops
I think already threatening these ideas
and even if A6 I still play Knight B5
because of the PIN
so A6 Bishop D3
there's Rook B8
take take I think I just saved the
knights
that didn't quite work out
question what's your Peak feeder rating
um it's like 24 20 something
[Music]
but that was back in 2015. I had a
series of like really good tournaments
I hadn't
haven't gotten close to
2400s in a while
okay eventually I want to play F4
maybe later at five if one person that
file opens
I'm see if takes I play Knight E3
[Music]
hey someone's getting merch thank you
someone
how to do this takes
this bishop B5 first
if ever it takes I take on D5
yeah these pawns are immaculate
oh no my Pawn
okay interesting finish to the game
also fun opening
a very joyful opening
top 200.
playing fish defend
Staffing avatime
we'll see how much my opponent knows
here
this is not considered to be the most
challenging line for black
um it might already be like preferable
for luck
but it's still tricky
it takes
it would be six castle maybe go for C5
light squares are vulnerable
F6
yeah so Knight F3 Queen E4 is winning
or is it 91
oh there's a funny line
91 Queen G2
oh no my queen let me make sure it works
though Queen G2 takes takes King G1
checkmate
oh no my queen
that's a cool idea you don't see too
often
allowing Knight takes G2 open the file
yeah there's one legal move here
so I think I'm still undefeated with uh
the Stafford
that was a fun one
okay don't play in Chicago okay
oh my streak
I have to win to keep my streak alive
yeah we always go into this line
let's see what he has in store this time
um there's a D3 first
yeah with a pawn there
Vlog might win it back but I have before
in store
E4 idea
G4 probably Rook C1
probably Castle here
New York fc1 and event of D4
giving up A2
C4
and this first
I take
not good
kind of nice position to
foreign
there is one still me trick takes takes
at stalemate
oh there goes my winning streak what to
do good game though
I had a great position
and then yeah this queen C4 move was
very strong
light burns a lot of time
I mean
I probably just have to give up the
b-pawn and maybe it was better decision
to keep cleans on the porn
yeah Queen E3
what to do
Life Goes On
I try and rebuild my streak
that may have been my best streak ever
I think there's a way to check like in
the chest stats
Okay so
on the threat
I gotta watch my time
pon's been playing very quickly
oh thank you teotaki
I don't have time to look at the
question now
um of the twin games
I think this is okay
very shaky though
I'll find a G5
or F5 Queen G5 Maybe
if white does nothing I just keep
pushing my a pawn
okay the square looks very juicy
let's just defend first
foreign
I really gotta watch my time
still pushing
this game took work
okay
oh
thanks for the consolation bucks
do you feel you become stronger since
you playing since you started playing
OTB again
um yeah I feel a little bit more Sharp
like generally when I play OTB
tournaments and then come back to
playing online
feels like I'm I'm seeing things of it
more clearly
it's definitely helpful
like something about playing long OTV
chess can really help
build like intuition and sharpness when
it comes to Blitz and bullets
okay so this is a classic setup for a
two nights attack
I'm going for this idea
hmm
if we trade
Knight G6
still trying to attack on the king side
even though Black's probably casting
Queen's side
it makes her happy
not sure what to do here
you see foreign prepared the ventral B4
the queen of seven
hmm
yeah I'll gamble the pawn
either C6 is coming or Bishop A3
that's a free Queen
okay
thanks uh to more people to Theodore who
too big faster than lightly
yeah we have a new streak
opponents taking their time
taking a lot of time okay
ponziani time
we're going to see the vukovic cabinet
again oh no we see this one oh we see
this one
it was like the classic ponziani trap
uh what's the line Queen B6 is like a
tricky move but
yeah here we
takes takes and then Fork
yeah Queen B6 is a main threat so
what's the best approach
I mean I'm up a pawn
most people don't find Queen V6 so
I'm taking my time here
probably just an id4
Knight D4 and then Bishop E3
I wasn't sure about Queen G4 F5 because
if it takes F2 would have been hanging
but now it works
and ponziani has been treating me well
thus far
uh I guess I'll win the queen
oh my queen
okay I'm still up of a rook
the nice thing about being up so much
material
paying a queen I'm still up a lot
uh like to Checkmate somehow
it's actually very close to meeting
okay I'll get the F maybe not get the
fork
wait let me watch my time
I'll simplify
I've been playing this game kind of
mindlessly
oh there we go okay
yeah this is like a very classic opening
trap
I assume there's been over 50 000 games
let's see
wow seventy thousand
yeah Bishop B5 is uh is winning
oops uh wait where's back to tournament
back to tournament
yeah maybe not the cleanest conversion
there but
okay building a new streak that's three
in a row
um play E5
offering a Stafford
oh Bishop B5
is the loss of tempo
this could transpose into like some
Italian
[Music]
yeah this is Italian territory
I should not have allowed this move
okay now it should be okay
uh it's a regain Focus
foreign
only two Defenders
I can have up to five attackers maybe
even six attackers
I guess there's some counter play like
Queen D6 in the end
I have Rook C8
uh how to do this
play this I might lose back the pawn
but I might not
foreign
Queen B7
Queen C8
trade with me
please
so I'm basically preventing the eventual
Queen E7
and we go into the same line
and there's no more Queen E7 because my
King's on f8
two pawns attacked
oh no my Rook
okay
game two rating points for that
you're actually working my way back to 2
800.
I just see I've played 99 games this
tournament is this my 100th game
try and make accounts
uh yeah I'm trapping The Rook now
okay one Bishop B2
I don't have to take it right away
just going for some confusion
eventually I want to play like maybe
B4 and C5
F5 might be coming
Bishop E4
white still has some practical chances
pawn store him in Knights
it does look a little bit scary like
nights out of play
hmm
I'm getting a fort
what to do
okay maybe I'm not getting forked
still very tricky though
I'm still allowing it like
okay now I have this move
this move
it's terrifying
foreign
maybe it's okay though
it's not good
losing the queen
okay opponent miss queen E7
okay oh man
oh what just happened there
okay
I was in big trouble like why you
probably had multiple wins but I'll take
it
uh the new streak continues
160.
six hours left
six hours and 27 minutes left
okay critical London line
Queen B2 is a bit more critical
I feel like I had this recently
um
I went for the same idea I'm pretty sure
it's a funny idea so basically a trade
but now the d-pawn's weak Bishops hits
still some pressure
foreign
is necessary
take
let's just win upon
okay the plan is Bishop B1 Queen D3 and
queen H7 checkmates
or maybe I I could just win D6
and then sack
thank you Badger lock
yeah I wanted to play this and this but
Queen does defend
now this is a big threat
Rook B6 yeah
so win back material
I'll keep it simple
okay
trying to get to 150.
oh playing a high rated player
who I drew once before
I'm going into this line
okay what's happening
foreign
[Music]
it's close to a draw but I feel like
there's some winning chances here
[Music]
foreign
oh we drew by repetition oops
ah a little bit too slow to work on my
mating technique with King and Rook
uh got the winning position to
well that's the first draw of the Stream
wow
yeah I was in time by like one tempo
there
just a little bit too slow
okay no raiding lost or gained
have a job London
haven't had one of these in a while
yeah the Deep one I guess just Falls
I have to be very careful here
uh what to do
six as a threat
is this a move
this might be a move
almost looks like I'm losing a queen but
Knight B3 Queen B3
Queen defends A2
oh that move I didn't see
but it's okay
or is it
okay it's equal material
welcome back to Bracken Dawson
happy 50 months
uh oh
okay this should be okay although
what's happening oh this is very okay oh
no my vision
okay
that worked out nicely
oh you're running a marathon tomorrow oh
good luck wow
I had the idea of like getting a
treadmill
and for the next marathon
like have the treadmill
in my stream setup
and then
run a marathon while playing movie Just
Marathon
so that that would probably be a big
challenge
okay what am I doing here a five
I want to play this
trying to prepare G5
hmm
if I play G4
it does closing Zone
maybe that wasn't the best option
I'm not feeling great here
foreign
[Music]
I think I can hold my ground
imagining some days sagging on
like E5
okay opponent socks first
I'm liking my chances now
Tricky Tricky
okay
I'm trying some triangulation there at
the end
I was in trouble that game
but we keep going almost top 150.
playing bubaling
who I've drawn every time that we've
played
oh they're the person who dirty flagged
me
and that King Rook ending
okay
time for Revenge hopefully
this is new territory
wait this is good territory
I think
or is it wait what's happening
or is it bad territory
I'm in trouble
what to do
but how much trouble or am I in trouble
I lose a queen
maybe it's okay
foreign
and rather not draw
but I might have to a five
no
I'm not this move
yeah I think it's just a drum
unless my opponent plays on
I'm down on time
foreign
how long can this game go
oh my time
okay
oh what to do Gigi
I should have taken the draw
but
then we wouldn't have such entertainment
there
okay I think that was my longest game of
the tournament
I was playing English opening
yeah I got dirty Flags again
this is a fun line
okay this might already be
problematic for black
okay I just want to hold on to the pawn
not easy to win the pond
at some point the bishop will defend
at some point I should make new tea too
see his reached room temperature
also castle at some points
so this Pawn is actually a Target
not easy to defend
okay
it was a nice English I won't play the
English again
been cycling through a lot of different
openings
yeah that's a free Pawn
okay I probably should have played
Bishop G5 there
that's okay developed normally
I'm not on an epic winning streak
unfortunately
unless you count my one game winning
streak
uh
okay I'm just gonna play a waiting game
I'm waiting for some opportunity
okay G4 G4 wins a piece
black will take
um I have to be a little bit careful
but the black queen can't come in
I'm controlling all the squares
Queen G5 looks nice
and it's an all-you-can-eat buffet
all over the board
the courses keep coming
okay
oh yeah I felt like Pac-Man I keep
eating the small dots
okay 150.
playing the person in 14th
uh let's mix it up
this is called the Vlog Mustang
transposing into
a reverse puritz
I think I win a pawn here
all right going after C2
I have to be careful
Rook D1
uh
okay this first
thank you
and Knight doesn't have too many squares
like Knight D2 and then I take
and life is good
Fork
there's a funny idea to play this move
takes and Rook d8
I'm just consolidating
I don't own a Mustang
unfortunately
maybe someday though
that's a good move
yeah not the car or the horse
uh okay let's move a little bit quicker
so up a pawn
it takes work
foreign
I had good chances there
even late into the end game
although here yeah here it's already
tricky I think I have to take or Bishop
Bishop B3 and then walk the king and
okay GG though
yeah I couldn't quite convert the extra
Pawn
oh no my streak again
the Life Goes On
um been playing a lot of different
things against our French
let's play uh another two nights attack
a lot of people are entering this line
yeah we might both Castle Queen side I
think I've discouraged back from casting
King's side
although A5 it's a sign
that will probably have a shark game
oh King's just chilling in the center
situations like this I probably want to
look for ways to open the center
like C4 G5
oops
okay that's not a good sign
uh blundering things
all right how to create chances
I won't need down a rook
take take
no queensry just yet although I'm lying
Bishop G5
uh it's not good
the hope is that the block can't
activate the Rooks
that's a very big hope
thank you
uh Chinese
oh okay
well that's that's one reason to play on
when being down a lot of material
Miracles sometimes happen
okay playing joyful scooter again
[Music]
last game was pretty joyful
okay one of these again
I've had a few opponents fall for this
trap
A4 doesn't really help because the whole
idea is to get the Knight to B4
which
do I want to go for here
I guess I will
okay
a delayed version of this uh same trap
so the point is G5 and The Bishop's
trapped
yeah difficult position for whites
probably the best move is this
takes takes Queen G5 and then sack
apologies again
this position is really nothing to
sneeze at
and look at this King
okay I could take the pawn
but is there a better approach
it's actually a funny line Knight D3
Queen D3 Bishop F5
Queen takes F5 Rook E3 checkmate
okay that was a very joyful game
thanks again chat for blessing me
okay
oh we had this line before
oh I remember that game
yeah that was a crazy game
opponent of blunder the d-pawn and then
I blundered back
uh just Castle
although wait no
I have to be careful
the bishop B7 first
uh oh
if I play this and there's this move so
I have to play this
which is maybe okay
I'm still up upon
just some weirdness happening on the
queen side
I think you just goofy
appreciate the five dollars
okay you have to be very careful here
Queen G5
eventually I just want to like push the
C Pawn
especially see one Queen H5
thank you Crosby 87 goats gifting to Dex
DX
how to do this
take take
I'll just push
okay the Knight is entering the game
wow
not sure what's happening anymore
I think things are under control still
I'm just getting a little bit crazy
okay so this attacks us and this
chicks takes
just play this
okay
oh that was close
oh man
um I'm gonna take a small break again
it's a long tournament
okay
[Music]
I refilled some tea
she got some energy bar too which I just
ate half of
welcome to all the pickles
a lot of people saying pickle okay
joining again
okay pentatonic for
for one game
but it makes me sleepy so
I have to make sure I I don't fall
asleep too soon
okay let's play a bishop B5 check
um I'll play the Slime Bishop A4
as what I played in Iceland
against a strong GM
[Music]
wow A5
this looks nice
takes takes
this is okay so it takes takes Knight C3
Queen C2 takes Bishop moves
or this line I'm in the pawn
oops
I'm in some trouble here
actually in a lot of trouble
ah that was not a good move
Queen two is possible
22 is still possible or cleaning one's
possible now
what to do
[Music]
I have two's falling
take
have to try this
foreign
[Music]
okay
can you remove the sound please
your wish is my command
da what am I doing
oh yeah sound okay back to normal
and trying to rebound here
I got a little bit too relaxed that game
okay I think tea is brewed for long
enough
uh sure blizzard back
yeah
really
[Music]
um
some compensation
okay
I think a draw is a fair result that
game
okay
oh my to my finger disconnected again
it did okay
my heart rate was higher than 77 there
thank you Google thank you to gooberfish
happy five months
oh my opponent there was in second place
wow
okay some strange opening
it's already Pleasant for whites
and this pin is uh pretty lethal
Rook D1 coming or queen side castling
coming
also threading this
so both Bishops are pinned
on the center files
maybe has an opportunity to take
or maybe not
take take
yeah this is just a dream position
like black is pretty much completely
paralyzed
okay 15 move win
yeah I'm trying to climb my way to the
top hundred
it's a very gradual Journey
we have some Kali system
I'm making a chart
some G5 ideas lingering
yeah A6 B6 I think is fine for me
if I take twice
wow
Chuck
I'll need next move
or at least in a few moves
okay
a nice quick win
I'm gonna finish my energy bar so I'm
gonna move the mic away from my my face
we'll have a quiet game
foreign
thank you
I would have liked to say oh no my queen
a mic was a little bit too far away
yeah this is a cool opening I discovered
this like 10 years ago
it was all prepped through bc3
and engine will give like a small Edge
for white
which means like there's full
compensation
okay
moving on
actually I discovered this opening after
encountering it from a black side
and I got crushed and then I learned it
from the white side
let's play in English
like the few games I played English I
had decent results
but here we have a qgd
I usually play the box side of this
position
hey it's someone getting merch
thank you someone
yeah this is Pleasant like usually black
does not Castle Queen side in these
lines
so unleashing the bishop on F2
wow
okay the choices here
and this looks nice
try and overpower the knights
Bishop D6
and Bishop B6 is coming
it's important not to overthink
I'm just trying to keep the game going
in a lot of issues still in Black's
position
okay four attackers Knight's pinned only
three Defenders
wow
where's my smothered means
start by taking
I guess I'll just simplify like
everything
[Music]
I'll be up two Pawns in the end
I'm down a little bit of time
okay
oh it wasn't easy
the opponent resisted a lot there
we have a new streak
I'm playing for a win
engine does not like this for black but
it's interesting
especially after Rook H2
okay
either the engine will say black has to
take the draw
like Queen D4 only move Knight G3 is
already plus four for white but the risk
paid off
still undefeated with the Staffing
thank you Silo Simon
okay playing for me
never played this upon before
oh it's Stafford gamut time okay let me
show it to how to actually refute the
Stafford
it feels bad doing this but
Stafford is objectively not a good
opening
uh
okay it feels kind of good position is
so nice for white
black didn't play the most like
challenging line though
it could have gotten a little bit more
messy
I think A2 is briefly hanging there
no mercy of that game
uh playing this opponent they beat me at
some point then I got revenge
oops okay
uh Cambridge Springs time
now we have
a typical qgd Exchange
usually the Queen's on C2 by now
I'm not sure if it makes a difference
the plan is to play this and this and
get the bishop hair
so E4 with the queen on C2 there's
Knight F4
um now I have this up a tempo
Play Bishop G4
so it should be in decent shape to
attack on the king side
and white was trying to play position on
the queen side this Pawn is
perhaps a long-term weakness
I'm just trying to throw the kitchen
sink at my opponent
all the pieces coming into play
G3 is coming
your Rook A3
I'm just trying to generate something
more pressure oh no my Pawn
actually made it is hanging
um
allowing light to take it
the plan was just Rook T8
another plan is this and this
I'm playing a little bit recklessly here
but maybe it'll pay off
I think okay two on the horizon
foreign
got the job done
almost top 100.
over five hours left
okay play the main line
uh what's the line here take some Bishop
here
opponent actually knows the theory here
not too many people know Bishop E7
still a playable position
oops meant to play Queen E2
threading a triple Fork
down on time but
am I just mating
I might just be meeting if it takes its
mates
all right let's hack
finally works
yeah one interesting thing about when
you're threatening a triple Fork
in this case like black couldn't get out
of it only one piece can move at a time
but then I didn't go for the Triple Fork
because the King was more valuable
okay
the apology is it's hard to keep up with
chat I can only do so much at once
especially after like so much chess
uh all right let's play 906 and maybe
Knights Tango maybe not
have like a what is this opening
uh Bishop Bishop G5 never mind variation
I think I just want to trade Bishops and
sure I'll wait for white to take
I'll leave some tension
but eventually like trade in 95 or not
maybe Queen D5
that's very close to equal
but if anything maybe there's some small
push
oh
okay so I'm gonna lose the C Pawn but I
get the Rook to A2
and there's this and this
or this and this
I think this maybe
so it's a bit stuck
a king can perhaps walk in
can you two I take the pawn
it was a cool end game I was down the
pond but a White's been very paralyzed
it's still not simple though
okay I have to defend E6
maybe it is simple
winning the pawn
that's four on two
I should play E5 there
and go back
okay back to this situation
okay
yeah maid is coming
okay pleasant game
my heart's still beating don't worry
thank you scary Pac-Man
okay playing Luca
uh berserk back
two nights attack
oh no my queen
yeah no one Falls for that
except maybe a few people
playing this
losing this maybe
we're both trying to attack on the king
side
okay
wow
I have to give back the queen
I guess I do
well played from Black
oh there's a funny uh it's not working
though
oh no my Pawn
I was almost background mated I had
Bishop G1 though
okay
how did you get the pre-moves in
wasn't super simple
oh I had Queen G4 yeah maybe I missed
Queen G4 there
the fatigue is kind of setting in but
hey I'm top hundred
okay
been playing a lot of this as
tournaments
in Cambridge Springs
yeah this is pretty harmless
um
I think I can still play this
gopher takes in C5
I have the bishop here
Queen can maybe swing over
this bishop wants to find a home on a
long diagonal
hmm
I'd like to attack
in Queen G5 and start pushing H Pawn
just abandoning the pawn
looks really close to being really good
again abandoning upon
I want to play Rook T2
or maybe even this move in Knight T2
Rook D2
0.92
and tricky threats
and essentially I just want to remove
the
thing from defending the other thing
wow
take take
I know this works
uh
well maybe it's okay though 93
I remove one thing so this thing's not
defended
after it takes takes King F1 Rook D2
then there's Queen B5 and I take the
Knight
so yeah this should be fine
and Pawn's kind of scary but
my attack should also be scary
okay defending
what's up Gary good to see you
if you're just joining it's been a lot
of Chess so far
but I'm I'm in the top hundred
382 tournament points 94th Place
Destroyer
one of us is about to get destroyed
I'll play this tricky line
A6 E5
I think this is already preferable for
lights
like the bishop serves the purpose of
discouraging Knight C6
okay let's play Bishop G5
and queen D2 some G4 idea
wow
I have a lot of choices here in G4
there's Bishop D5 maybe bishop D5 first
and then G4 just so there's no like
counter play
lights trapped but there's G5
G5 take take Rook G1
okay F6 is coming
so I didn't win a piece I could still
equal material but now now I'm winning a
piece
oh Knights attacked
um
okay we'll play a very positionally
I think group D2
and eventually maybe push the H Pawn
C2 is defended enough times
I've forged my knights with my Pawn
it's a defensive Fork
okay
foreign
ERS today but I'm I'm focusing on the
marathon
it's a more
um more prestigious event
It's a larger tournament
never played this up on the before
and staff for gamma time
this line people usually don't go for
the line here is 94 Queen E2 takes
that's also a line
I think I can just Castle
so I went back the pawn
uh oh
I really just allow that
there's almost 93
and G3 take take
my G3 might be my best try
I got too comfortable
at least it takes a little bit of work
for white to win the knights
you might will have a
what
two pieces for rook and pawn probably
uh
yeah my Knights are gone are
lived a good life
probably could have been treated better
I want to keep my Bishop I want to trade
darks were Bishops
easier said than done
at least the position is kind of
stabilized
I'm not sure what my plan is
maybe I am sure
okay
it's a tactical gift
up on time and finally a material
okay now anything can happen
back to equal material
uh there there
King G8
okay I'm winning the bishop
what a messy game
it's still tricky too
King wants to come to C6
okay very messy game
I'll take it though
I went a little bit astray in the
opening there
uh
I'll take
let's set up to play Let's play this one
eventually want to play C5
um good move
there it takes takes
not sure if I can make C5 work
um
I think I just do it
I'll be down the pond but at least I can
breathe a little bit
and the Knight can come to C6 perhaps
so block hands and defends
Queen can come to B5
or maybe not
scared about my king sign
maybe it's okay though
wow
I don't see the maybe I do see the point
take your
rook and Bishop are hanging
this Rooks attack now
God move fast
faster
not good
okay I'm happy with the draw there
I think I was on the back foot that
whole game
thank you shabbat Benji I appreciate the
the sub and the words
okay
uh London time
uh Free Pawn
two Pawns
maybe being a little bit too safe
yeah getting kind of passive should
probably get back upon
just Castle
I'm not proud with the way I handled
this
but Life Goes On
me a five
man
I'm trying to untangle it's not easy
though
Bishop's really misplaced
am I Bishop getting trapped
in this move
and D4 if necessary
on Queen F5 though
wow
what's happening
um
that is not so clear
let's do it because it looks fun
it's really not so clear
oh dear
this doesn't work at all
oh my gosh
no
ah
I'm so angry
I've rage paused okay let's rejoin
what to do
yeah I went for a line that I probably
just shouldn't have
okay tilt berserk
okay B4 was not necessary
ooh
this looks fun
okay that's how it's untilt
I'm untilted now type 90
playing hub
Play the song
that Quincy it's uh I think considered
to be better just because of this idea
haven't played this in a while haven't
looked at this in a while
um of this move
Rook D1
so I'm threatening to take twice and
then play C4
back
threat remains
we might see Knight five B6
right really
if I take
and then take
okay I'm on a piece
as an opening success
okay again three reading points for that
so almost 400 tournament points
top 20 and still above 500.
I'm going to the sign
I think the move is Knight H2
don't fully remember though
it's two there
maybe this first
and now issue is now a threat
it's getting spicy
there there
just preserve the bishop first
I should have taken oh actually this is
fine H2 is vulnerable
but there's C5 coming
so there's a D4 first
I wanted to take but I wasn't sure
and this should be good now
okay I think I just play this
just abandon the whole Queen sign
if Queen takes B7 I sacrifice
The Rook actually both Rooks
both Rooks
because after it takes King D7 takes I
checkmate
otherwise I
have Rook H1 checkmates
if only I could say the Rooks with more
enthusiasm
oh it's such a funny position though
it was a fun attack
King G7 I could sacrifice the queen
wait does that work takes nah let's
let's be civil
only sacrificing the Rooks
I wanted to play Queen Dick's G3
checkmates
okay that was a fun game
oh yeah the screen has to shake
intensely
okay
[Music]
I just minimized all my windows
okay uh let's play this
top 80.
play C4
[Music]
it was a tricky move order play A3 first
taking my time
wait a minute H3
I want to play D4 eventually
Knight D4
okay now I want to play B4 eventually
tracking upon Maybe
C4 is still hanging potentially
actually we have a very chill position
[Music]
and both sides are relatively solid
I have a slightly worse Bishop
but some b-file pressure
I want to play Rook G2
I'm not too concerned about this battery
b-files blocked
the Rooks might Shuffle over yeah
so G5
G5 is interesting
calculating Rook here takes
hmm
I'm taking way too much time
I don't know what to do though
in D4
allows Bishop C4 but it's interesting
foreign
my Bishop's so sad
yeah I'm all playing
wait for it wait for it wait for it wait
for it
yes okay
oh that's the first uh classic stalemate
trap of this tournament
oh it didn't have to wait too long for
it
okay
I'm so happy The Physician was so sad
there
and my Bishops didn't come to life
okay
slaw the sevens here in two seven seven
seven seven seven seven seven okay
wow interesting Gambit
well it has compensation
my Bishop's stuck
gradually trying to untangle
I think I'll just sack the The Rook
it was this idea
it's a funny idea
threatening made in one I had Bishop F3
but
Bishop age one is funnier
yeah that defends
but now in this move wow look at the
harmony of the pieces
so many long-distance relationships
okay
that was a fun game
okay ponziani time
another vukovic Gambit
what's the line here Rook G1
I think there's a few moves here
I always forget the theory after a
certain point
this looks okay
I'm up a piece
all right
I mean the king is kind of just
enjoying the open world
94's maybe coming
I mean really I just want a complete
development
I really want to punish this Knight
in this move now
all right this move
c596
Knight g496
there's a crazy line
uh Bishop C4 I'm just leaving the Knight
chilling if it takes takes I win the
queen light's still trapped
uh now I can take on C5
some back rank ideas
Queen F5 Bishop D3
don't know my queen
someone called ambulance
but not for me
yeah black is losing a queen or getting
Maiden
oh
okay that was a cool game
it's my second time running into this
opening against panziani
and it's very very sharp but it shows
that like
as black if you play this you really
have to know how to get full
compensation
[Music]
um
because yeah it's sometimes fun being up
material
all right I'll keep playing E4
and let's play
oh this is a
what Levy was playing against me in our
match
about a year ago
I think I'm supposed to take oh my
Bishop's supposed to be here though
okay I lost a tempo
okay I have the bishop pair
probably not quite threatening the sack
but
that's a potential idea
I think G5 is a concession
although F5 might be coming if I would
hang the pawn
okay no Queen trade just yet
and now it looks like I'm winning a pawn
oh there's this move
okay things are really closing down
I'm trying to open things up a little
bit
a small trick
yeah this way blacks left with some weak
Pawn
we might see the exchange stock
otherwise I just cleanly win the pawn
oh maybe I don't
yeah maybe it's still like roughly equal
materials equal
this Pawn could be weak
it's a very strategic ending
I have a slightly better Bishop at least
ideas Rook G4
[Music]
that's still Pleasant
ooh
The Rook worms its way in
poking and prodding
thank you
okay
that took work
the poking paid off
I've lost track if I've lost a game in
the Stafford
I had like a long winning streak with
Saturn
and keep it up
this is not like a true Stafford
accepted
a pleasant position have the bishop here
that's hard to resolve for whites
although Queen D3 is a move
that's also a move can I take
not worth it
okay another off the color Bishop
position coming up
in Queen H4
some F6
try this
here here
I couldn't play that five first
perhaps
I'm trying to break the defenses somehow
there's an idea uh takes after it takes
Bishop E4
although that doesn't work anymore
never mind
well the queen on D1 it would have
worked
um
so this Pawn a weakness or a strength
Bishop A3 is a big threat
I think I'm threatening to take in
Bishop E4
and there's Queen takes yeah it's still
very tricky
but now I'm threatening this and this
essentially winning the pawn
uh oh
just blender everything
wow
I just gave away everything
as a mating that
I have this move though
the queen is somehow safe
uh but maybe not safe
What's Happening Here well it has at
least perpetual
I feel so dirty
oh what a crazy game
and queen D3 was not a good move
it's incredible that my king just has no
Escape I wanted to play H5 it takes King
H6 and G5 checkmates
so I think King age seven was the best
try
yeah and then it should be a draw
objectively but then
I had to keep giving checks
yeah I like game
okay thank you Francis Wayne happy five
months
so 70 first place
top 20 is still very far away
okay we have one of these
yeah they used to get the Knight to C5
and it's a positional battle
foreign
this might be a good move
G5 was very unexpected
all right so B5
I think the queen wants to do things on
the king side
okay I'm thinking
I have to take
this move
that wasn't good allowing this
it's still a fight I'm worse here
A5 oh yeah yeah
let's try this
gotta run with a pawn
some counter play
I might be winning am I winning here
I don't see the defense for a buck
I guess that could take
but then I shouldn't be worse
oh there's this line too
it sounds like with the King
I think this should be winning
because my king will walk all the way up
and then find shelter on E7
oh maybe it's not winning
it's not winning
there's my king go
okay black was desperate hard position
to move quickly
um wow
yeah it turned around like weirdly
quickly
black had to be really careful of the
pawn
like around here
after H3
maybe Rook C2
Rook C2 and then get the rook in
okay
play E4
have appearance
transpose back into the usually when I
play from a London
there's some E5 ideas
yeah trying to set up E5
Blackhand Castle
hmm
you know takes I had made
okay creating the battery
and the leader has over a thousand
points it's crazy
hmm
F3 no
Envision D3
actually not thrilled with the position
but
oh there's this move
I could be in some trouble if black
finds it
not the easiest move to find though
yeah I'd taken
play this
foreign
so hitting the bishop
here here here here
Queen's out of play
three attackers against F7
[Music]
blocking the queen
the apology is that I really have not
been looking much at chat
where did Eric go in the UAE
uh I played in Abu Dhabi back in August
I was also in Dubai for the world
championship match
all right let's berserk
interesting
yeah this already looks really nice
wow
let's start with this
check
it's kind of like a maze the queen just
wants to get to F2 or win a rook
uh there there
let's win The Rook
I am moving a little bit slowly but
position makes up for it
yeah no more Queen trade
ah
nice timely resignation
okay
nice place
top 70.
stand for again but time declined
isn't there a funny line here
I'll just take
not so tactic
well I got another tactic
oh F5 is coming
I'm the one getting tactic
maybe it's okay though
still tricky
uh
ah what to do
okay I guess I keep the darks for Bishop
and back to equal material
we'll have some interesting end game
it should be possible to play for a win
here
although c4d5s coming
yeah yeah yeah
so preparing this
I think I'm just in time
wow
there
foreign
I think I have to play this
I'm actually not sure about the
valuation
very tricky ending to try and figure out
especially with a little time
now I should be in decent shape
I've got the password on the queen side
okay man
that was a very tricky ending
I got a reading point for that
playing fish defend again
last game they couldn't really defend
against my attack oh that was a fun
staff organic Queen sack game
oh what opening am I playing here
playing like some Scotch Goring Gambit
allowing def actually no that was fine
yeah position seems fine
um
C5 Knight B5
going after this Pawn
I think you see back happy seven months
okay a lot of things vulnerable for
black
I want to do cool things but
this just calls for some patience
okay now let's do some cool things
oh no my queen
so Queen D4 Queen G6
not completely over
it looks good though
I want to play Rook G7 soon
and this first
so we're threatening made into
and time to Rick lift
okay
okay 66th
um slowly but surely trying to break my
way into the top 50.
I'll play E4 again
as Stafford declines good for black
yeah generally it's slightly better like
objectively
it's essentially a Petrov but white has
lost a tempo
so it's it's usually black having more
fun
I was supposed to play Knight D2 to F1
before castling
I don't play these lines too often
uh
I think I went a little bit wrong there
but maybe it's not so bad
just a little bit less space
the night's coming here
[Music]
yeah not the most Pleasant situation
night's still coming in
she takes a knight D4 in his wins
something I think
yeah this is not good for me
Brooke here is my best try
so I'm down the pond
that could be worse
at least my pieces have found like
decent homes
up at a time
that's a good move
take take
let's try this
actually let's not go too crazy
I'll try this
another five is a nice threat
essentially trapping The Rook
G6 would not stop it
and it's still just worse here though
but I'm up in time
using the clock as a weapon
just have to survive for a little bit
longer
oh
oh yeah yeah
all played from Black
okay it's a draw
this is proof that chess is just a draw
oh man
okay
opponent football that game like I was
under
pretty bad pressure
G3 I think I can take in C5
okay let me try and defend the pawn
okay
E5
now let's take some Bishop E3
but this should be roughly equal
assuming light takes and wins the pawn
back
realizing this was probably not a great
decision
all right it's very quick to get the
rook in
maybe it's okay though
this is Media threats
it looks passive
but the b-pawn is probably the biggest
weakness here
yeah it doesn't quite work for me
wow
good move
I'm definitely not better here
uh
maybe I'm holding
the idea to play Bishop A4
so Rook C4 I take
ah
very difficult position
I want to play this move
okay trading off one pair of Rooks
should be some success
and King Pawn ending is probably just a
draw
I'm definitely not worse here anymore
yeah this is just a draw
do I go insane
oh
okay now it's winning for me
yeah white white should have just kept
trying to repeat
and we probably would have repeated
okay somehow I won that I was under
pressure the whole game
oh I think I know this person
yeah I know this person
it's ilko we met in Romania
in 2018 I think
super friendly
not sure if he's watching but
I I hope I'm remembering correctly
maybe there's another person with the
same name
okay we'll see how much Stafford he
knows
yeah the best move here is not easy to
find the best move is E5
and like if you don't know it and don't
have enough time it can be hard to
actually figure out
okay
so what's the approach here takes takes
I guess I'm just winning material
we'll trade it's not the fanciest way to
like convert the attack but
dull I had ruggage one oops
I was still lingering ideas of Rook H1
all right let's play this move
I just plunder I just blundered
was blocked into a pin
okay now
what do I have to do to play this
probably want to keep those Rooks on the
board right now
you like trade
I guess I trade
I mean objectively white smudge powder
hmm
I can win the pawn
that's not good
no
that's gonna be a draw
it's a drug cocaine
oh
it was a nice opening I'm actually
curious
was uh I should have just played um Rook
H1
[Music]
The Rook
okay I still got a what a point for that
playing this opponent again
um go into this
this is another like Carol Khan
kirganize
a knight of six Bishop D3
just trying to be solid here
and black is also kind of solid
I might get the oh I might get forked
that's not good
takes takes takes
I mean let's go for this
yeah the play is getting messy
Fox defending
that's a move too
all right B4
I can take here
that's a good move
I'm down two pieces
I just realized I thought it was only
down one piece
so two pieces for three Pawns
there's not much hope
I gotta use my Pawns
so they're full potential
some tricks come back four maybe coming
back for achieved
not so simple for black
you know how I've managed to make this
happen
I didn't want to play F6 let me keep my
Pawns
it's incredible
attack
like it's just about winning now
how I'm winning this
wow
what just happened
so I was down a piece
at least in my mind and then I realized
I was down two pieces
how did that happen
sysacton nights oh and I sacked the
bishop
but then my pawns just became like
monstrous
wow
okay
so trying to get back to 2800
from a long journey
we have a bullet game
oh dude we have a purple King that game
we may have
emberg being very observant
okay let's play this maneuver
at some point I'd like to achieve
I'll post on D4
coming soon
uh it's not meeting
moving way too slowly here
okay some pressure oh I got mated
oops
F4 was a tricky move
ah I need better board vision
okay
try and learn my lesson
uh I'll play this
should be pleasant
okay so we both have some damage
structure
yeah the problem for black is I'm going
to invade via the G file
there's never Rook G8
okay
trying to get back on track
wow there's over 22 000 players in this
tournament
it's a lot of players
thank you guys Eagles first time rhyme
son
okay playing Frank Murat from Lafia
I'm playing reverse London
a queen is probably better like back
where it came from
foreign
typical break here
E4 was a bit committal
it's interesting but
this Pawn is going to be a long-term
weakness
I have the D5 Square now
I mean take on E5 we trade everything
[Music]
wait what am I thinking that loses a
piece
okay let's play G5 first
yeah white has three Defenders
maybe this
I'm going to transfer the bishop to E7
thank you to Elton Speculator another
first time run
go to be careful here
let me just gradually improve
G6 King G7
okay this should be nice
yeah all these pawns are gonna fall
unless my Bishop gets trapped
have to be a little bit careful
oops
was I not careful
I think it's still okay though
ready to win the pawn
okay
I'm playing Dark Hunter
supposed to work back
on this line
yeah there's some crazy lines here
um
that doesn't work at all
it does it
Maybe
it could be working
maybe it's working
it's a very theoretical variation of
London
yeah double pin
okay let me check that line real quick
uh
I mean we were following like Master
Theory
there's a Wesley Soul game here
so I'm supposed to take ah so Queen C5
is not a good move
Queen A3 is the best move
or queen A5 is the best move and then
castling okay
Bishop G7
Knight C4 wow
what is this
uh just take and
okay
uh good to know
okay on the streak
three in a row
okay we have a
London but from a different side
and I wants to be on A5 or on A4
let's start with this
okay now Begins the night maneuver
I'll try the pair of Rooks
but not all the Rooks
okay B2 is the Target now
still tricky
there's pressure but
I want to actually make progress
this actually looks promising
King G3 I have rookie two
I should be winning another Pawn
discouraging Knight B4
this is maybe not the best technique
okay now we force a trade
okay
pay has received our Bailey thanks for
the rain I didn't realize that was two
minutes ago
I've been so focused on these games
uh do appreciate it shout out to nasif
it's a former Webster teammate of mine
let me uh spelled his name incorrectly
hope you had a good stream
so if you're just joining this is a 2023
spring Marathon
I've played for many many hours
about five and a half hours into the
Stream
I played for about three three hours
last night
so it's been a lot of chess
currently 56th
out of
like 20 something thousand people
okay this should all be fine Knight C1
4 H5 coming
oh I missed a free rook oops
I actually like I was hanging for two
moves too
I was wondering why I've never seen this
idea but Brook was just hanging
oops
okay at least I can find other free
material
yeah Connect Four trapping the bishop
uh play G4
okay
the top 20 is still very far away
we have another bullet game
yeah this is supposed to be better for
black I think
well maybe it's just playable for both
sides
okay this is looking nice
little weird configuration here
how's my Rook doing
okay I don't trade
foreign
that was a funny mate okay
ah thank you cue psycho first time Prime
thank you Bubba
okay
berserk
we'll play the sign
yeah a lot of the players are not
prepared for Knight C3
I'll take and play E4
um
okay nice eight move win
almost top 50.
the goal is top 30. that was like the
best spot in the prediction I ran
prediction ended about a few hours ago
okay going for this attack
I'm transposing into some kind of dragon
I kind of sack the knights
there's also Knight C6 which is
interesting
I think I'll start with Knight C6
and then 97 and then H5
seems like a difficult position for
black
okay there goes the queen
I think a lot of my opponents have been
playing for much longer than I have
like I've been playing for a long time
but it's possible some people have been
playing for the last 20 hours
so as the tournament goes on it's so
much easier for players to
suffer from fatigue and hallucinations
and queen blunders
there's a fun line G5 F4
maybe not quite happening
okay it's Queen side Castle
F5 would be a fun move to get in
yeah hopefully not
lullaby intention
so light's pinned
now the Bishops pinned
Dole
okay that's one check I just didn't see
it coming thankfully my queen was not
hot enough too
H4 I've actually prepared this in the
past
I forget what I prepared though
okay let's just push
I think I'm supposed to take
trying to use a square
yeah it'd be nice to trade lights for
Bishops because then D3 becomes a lot
weaker
Bishop
take first
okay just trying to make the pieces
happy
Rook G2 on the horizon
proxy8
and this move
might be threatening Knight D3 Queen G3
not rushing though
feels very wrong giving away the bishop
but now Knight D3
I'll try it
let's have it in Queen takes there there
King runs to D2
like your Rook G2
looks good
Bishop's pinned I have the C file
play this move
idea Bishop G4
okay that's a good move
hmm
I've gone terribly wrong
okay
well that could have gone much more
wrong
somehow managed to
get the flag
yeah my attack backfired I think I was a
little bit too fancy there
all right this is a fun line
hitting the g-pawn
it's one of these like tricky London
lines that's
black doesn't have to allow
but when black does allow
it can be pleasant
um
I think F3 four Bishop D3 first
now we're trading a lot
I'm Gonna Keep Queens on the board
dark Spurs are a bit weak
my Pawn
I think the pawn is poisonous because
here and then I sack and then mate
there is this move that then takes and
here
it was a funny line
okay threatening this maybe
so it's equal material but my Rooks are
more active
they're they're the black ones should
Checkmate me
let's just play this
and then Rook C7
it's actually still very tricky
black should be the one under pressure
and Rook F7 is coming
and then probably another Pawn
oops
what did I do
okay it's a draw
or is it
by losing I'm losing
oh no
draw
how they found the win
I can't believe I allowed that
uh what to do
hmm
[Music]
um
though
oh so sad
I'll just allowed the thing
had to keep my Pawn defended
yeah some fatigue setting in but okay
let's talk berserk
opponents Works back
try and get back on a
happier note
okay V for victory
play
and G3 is a good sign
okay
oh
very fancy
I've gone wrong again
let's play this
no it's not still neat
I'm so sad I was setting up a stalemate
trick
uh that feeling when
King takes E6 is played and the game
doesn't end
because I saw the bishop controlling but
it's not it's not a stalemating pattern
what to do
okay top 50.
that's the first time in a long time
I've lost two in a row
I think
let's try and rebound
okay Italian time
take take
and it's not so easy for white to
resolve the PIN
and H3 will come
running this
was actually a very pleasant game
okay
so three hours left
30 is
okay so 513
oops okay that was muscle memory
I think I'm giving time odds here
unless my opponent berserk's back
nope
foreign
maybe it's okay
King will run back to where it belongs
Now berserking isn't actually that bad
at least in a case like this where
okay Lock's been spending more time
not too far down on time
Bishop C2 Bishop D3
foreign
still some work to do
I think I just want to start pushing the
d-pawn
but the queen on D4
you know this is not perpetual
okay
got some berserking points there
um do I continue
well my opponent berserk back maybe not
yeah this is probably a bad decision
Pawn takes usually the bishop takes
foreign
all right
okay got some more Biz working points
um I'm gonna take another small break uh
let me pause the tournament
and reflect on how many games I've
played
played 160 games maybe I'll get to 200
at some point okay rejoining
I got some coconut water
organic
also transparent partly
all right let's play E4
and is this the person who plays the the
googanity or no
okay two nights
um
yeah this line
I know I'm supposed to take
and I think just like D3 and play the
setup
I haven't looked at this line in a while
I vaguely remember some Hikaru fantasy
of game
but it was probably a bit different
um
okay allowing the trade
D4
when Pawn can't be taken
okay sagging the b-pawn
was mostly intuitive but
just trying to get the pawns rolling
wow somehow trap with Bishop
okay both Bishops and both Rooks
like a dream attacking setup
also upper piece
wait a minute
can be a little bit careful
yeah so now I can take and move back
unfortunately I can't really discover
attack anything all of that things are
on light squares this bishop can't
attack anything
or maybe now can it
gotta move a little bit more quickly
here
so I'm threatening this
okay now I can take
and check
it's a cool mating pattern
yeah I got both Rooks
smiling on the files
okay
44th approaching 500 tournament points
okay we'll play this line
am I losing a pawn
I might be
yeah I'm losing upon
but after it takes all Castle
maybe there's some compensation
Queen A3
oh this Pawn's a bit weak
now b3i chocolate Rook
okay that move was a good move
um
yeah I'm just down the pawn here
maybe still some pressure though
the bishop pair offers some compensation
wow
well played I was under pressure
basically the whole game
what to do
I'm playing geek 76.
H5 G6
um
very fancy
yeah my Bishop's not happy here
uh what to do
I'm really playing without a plan
black is so solid
okay maybe now I can do something with
the Pawns
King comes E4
foreign
D5 let's play this first
this is a move that's also a move
wow
foreign
just a draw
no it's not a draw takes takes
King beats a move
okay
I guess we drew
um yeah the night was tricky
I infiltrated with my king the black
infiltrated with a knight
okay
so I have about three hours to try and
get back or get into the top 30.
um
maybe doable
okay I'm going all out here
I want to play E4
the light beat me to it
so this is a cool idea because after it
takes
I've been threatening mates and both
Bishops and now everything's hanging
okay that worked out nicely
I'm playing Carlson
a little bit differently
I messed up this opening earlier
but we have a slightly different line
okay all Castle queenside
looks Pleasant
um looks very pleasant
yeah the final few hours of the
tournaments we're gonna see probably a
lot more blunders
a lot more quick games
okay a fork is coming
okay 43rd
no berserking gonna try and get my re oh
okay all those work
if my opponent berserks I observed back
okay this is already Pleasant for whites
foreign
thanks for the read hope you had a good
stream
if you're just joining I'm playing the
spring Marathon
it's a long long tournament I'm trying
to stay awake
I'm trying to not get too attacked
although
this is a little bit unsettling
I think I'm surviving
yeah it was just under three hours to go
time scramble incoming
foreign
[Music]
okay
I had too little time to figure out how
to mate with two queens
I had to go for the long distance by
checks
oh man
okay
so with one more win I'll break 500
.
I actually don't know if this is theory
it might be might not be
looks okay though
complete development
yeah this is a usually the structure I
like to get
into London put the Rook back on the a
file
B3 I think was maybe a little bit too
weakening
yeah oh no my Rook
I probably could have just taken the
pawn
wasn't the most necessary move
foreign
not too far away from zagalko
okay no berserking
a London time
hey I got to 500 points
on some achievement
I'm not sure if I've ever scored 500
points in
Arena tournaments
I'm actually not sure what my best like
Marathon finishes
yeah this looks a little bit shaky at
first but uh I think there's enough ways
to
make the pawn useful
because whatever it takes on
I'll get some panchain
Black's actually a bit stuck here like
King side down to a couple things
relax just waiting
I can wait too
yeah maybe each four
yeah this is really nice
although
I have to give back the pawn
um I might have to play F4 here
there is an idea let's try this bishop
G2
ideas to trap The Rook
okay still a fight
okay let's not get mated
I already messed up
okay that was close
I really like the position for the
opening and then something happened
playing a strong player actually they're
in first place
so maybe they're tired
I'm kind of tired too though
it'll trade a bit
yeah okay I'm okay
everything's fine
okay oh
[Music]
took down the leader
unfortunately they're still leading by a
lot
1184 points man
I was in trouble that game but
my knight proved to be tricky
all right jerk
um
yeah this is Pleasant
already in Greek gift
okay a quick win
eight points away from 2800
okay more people berserking
oh no my queen
I don't know why I played this opening
it's not you it's not good at all
but uh
it's a funny trick
so I'm down upon thank you Tuesday June
I appreciate the 1 000 nice win bets
okay there's some compensation here
maybe
The Rook on d8
thank you fing Duster
getting closer to talk 30.
opponent disconnected briefly there
um
what's happening
I want to take and meet
this doesn't work
or does it
I guess it kind of works
okay
it was quick enough there that was a
confusing game
it's fp3 the third
welcome back infinity
I appreciate the energy
could use some energy now
I'm uh
six hours and 40 minutes into the Stream
thank you Gary uh 1 000 Victory bits
Hazard with the first time Prime
oh I didn't berserk back
I was too busy thanking people
okay so I have some nice timeouts here
uh uh the A3
thank you Christine HP
okay this is a fun looking position
uh
but how to make it even more fun
Maybe by losing material
the files are now open
[Music]
um
okay I have my sniper Bishop
I don't know what my Bishops are doing
there there
let's take
I want to play this move
okay let's Castle
never too late to Castle
thank you fluffy bunny
wow
okay Bishop's pinned and attacked
oh that move didn't work at all oops
I thought it was being clever
okay maybe
Knight's pinned now
Chuck
what's happening
I think I'm gonna win on time
okay
black was so fast there wow
but I was slightly faster
also why has my heart rate just stayed
at the same beat the whole time
at some point I took off my watch and I
forgot I took off my watch
I don't know why I took off my watch
or maybe it's a charges
okay
thank you banana peel
also cheering a thousand bits
and evils with us six months
okay 34th Place
here we go again
[Music]
um yeah this line
it's a tricky liner
there's a game between Hikaru and
siddler
very similar line I think Fiddler played
Bishop G4 instead of Knight G4
uh oh
I have this move
Bishop Athlon
I always play Bishop F1
this is terrifying I'm not even
threatening to take
I guess the plan is to play Bishop G2
which I can't do
let's have some staff are Gambit finds
double pawns Initiative for black
trying to make sure things are intact
foreign
things are under control now
f4 on the horizon
I take
foreign
D5 King G1
which is made in two
that's made into
okay
hey I'm back over 2800.
I've broken even for the tournament
I started the tournament at 2800 exactly
I'll find a strong player now
uh let's play this
oh no
okay how bad is this though
There Goes My Queen
no that's pretty bad
it's really bad
young children close your eyes
or is it bad
yeah it's bad
King f8
uh
what to do
I'll resign soon
like right now
I played a little bit too quickly there
what did I do I I think I was expecting
Pawn digs like
that's why I basically pre-move D5 with
Knight takes I had to Castle
okay
27.99
okay no tilting
berserk back
okay go for G5
oh
have a very similar situation earlier
one of my earliest games in the
tournament
okay let's be careful
foreign
Rook is about to be trapped
or just hugged
no it's gonna get out
um
okay
and you get the timing down there
back over 2800
thank you I play Sicilian dragon
should I play the Sicilian Dragon next
game
let's pre-move C5
I'll play Sicilian Dragon regardless of
what white plays
uh D6
takes
okay this is a slightly different line
but I can still play a dragon setup
it's actually a very pleasant position
already
some issues for white
visit H6
um
I was hoping for more
still trying to play aggressively
wow
I really want to punish this move but
okay Bishop E6
it takes I open a file
takes takes
and what if I take here
okay let's be a little bit safe
still trying to play aggressively
that pawn is a very clear Target
ing this
okay finally got some tactics
okay thank you I placed the ceiling
Dragon for the inspiration
32nd Place
trying to remember the opening we played
earlier
okay we have a nozzle was
a crazy position
so much fun
it was a sack
that's not good
let's go
okay
okay I'm officially gaining rating this
tournament
I forgot to berserk
sorry opponent
I'll gladly have time odds
I have to cool down after that last game
thank you Fame Duster
okay
some B5
very intuitive sacrifice so takes takes
e-file opens
um
take care first
foreign
B3 would be tricky
okay
31st Place
playing light like
stop for Gaba time
no one's really tested me in this uh the
magical line
so F3 here Bishop F3 is like kind of the
common move these days
F4 is a move too
with F4
oh it's a line there
I just still go for this
and this is why I play the Stafford it's
it looks dubious White's probably
winning objectively but it's so crazy
okay I have this move
actually might as well just take
oh White's probably actually just
winning objectively
uh oh
I have to play this
and if I take
let's go for this
it still gets weird running mate in one
to defend everything
Rook H3
oh good move
I could take the bishop
still some counter play
take
but not much
well it's kind of struggling
that's still losing though
or is it
no
wow
yeah there was a missed work at some
point
uh in this position
okay Stafford gamut is unbeatable
oh I was losing like the whole game
probably
played well
am I supposed to do against F4
is white just winning
H4
yeah it's just a bad line for black
it looks cool at first
so Bishop B6 okay
oh yeah I remember this bishop B6 and
then most people play E5 and then
Black's doing fine after Queen G6
okay
the Stafford Theory
so still over two hours left
on the streak
this is a tricky line
a lot of people wonder D5 Knight B5
Bishop B4 is the best move
and then this is usually the follow-up
remember there's some Richard report
game
where he played H4
and like just leaves the king
or leaves a rook on each one
and they shoot for black castling King
sidewalks under Queen E4
although maybe it's playable on a five
all right let's have some fun
not your conventional
way to develop The Rook
ooh
very fancy
so my rook's trapped
and I take
okay so much regrets
it's still playable Maybe
still very playable
like very very very playable
oh
let's be careful
and this move
so I'm kind of pinned
a weird situation
I'm other Bishop okay
should be enough to win
oops
and this move
okay as long as I don't allow a rook
have one Jack
okay mate is coming
okay I'm getting some more rating
that you decentralized the first time
Prime
okay this is the trial that I was
talking about in the previous game
it was Knight B5
7's hard to defend
foreign
for two minor pieces
okay I'd like to keep things simple
still kind of a fight
foreign
's a little bit out of it
but no need to do anything too crazy
Pawn should fall
a box very pinned down
okay
that's a nice streak going
555 29th Place
seven minutes or seven hours and 12
minutes into the Stream
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube let me know if you've made it
this far
usually it's only like less than two
percent of viewers at Mega's to the
seven hour mark
okay playing the strong player here
I've had the sign a few times
foreign
no need to play A6 A6 B6
if I get the knights F4 the queen can
come to H3
leads to some mating ideas
my time ticking for
don't know I might move there
okay having some hallucination
oh my queen
I had to play Queen G5 oops
oh I miss her so much
it was such a good position to
at least I win connect five
a consolation prize
I'm so sad now
I'll still try and attack
it's more fun to attack with the queen
uh
that's so sad in this move
these moves like almost work
like really almost works
[Music]
um
and lose most of my hope
uh what to do
okay
oh so sad
the the position did have Swindle
potential
not quite enough
all right let's mix up the opening
English opening time
and qgd
yeah we'll play in a very classical
Style
hmm
it's a little bit reminiscent to the
like nepo ding game
it's A5 setup
[Music]
I'm not getting much here
I eventually want to play like B5 B4 or
B4 B5
but it takes patience
actually Vlog allowed B4 for a moment
and still does
and this is what I want
it's uh it's actually a very simple
example of a minority attack
it was two on one
trying to induce some weakness
and box pawns are a little bit weaker
now
I'm not sure if I can exploit it
and D4 is coming
oh that moves ah
okay let's play this
still be okay
why do I keep plundering my queen
queens move backwards
I'm so sad again
yeah that's that's not even stalemate uh
I had Pawns
uh
I had to move my queen there what to do
yeah I need to just power through
let's not get too tilted
what's the best way to untilt
do I go full berserk tilt
okay if I can win this game I'll
hopefully un tilt
oh this is opening
some weird Kings get it
I think I'll try and hold on to the pawn
not sure how easy it'll be
but King is pretty safe
yeah very low risk position now
that's a
okay
not sure if this is the best approach
I've really butchered this
let's go
okay
oh
that took a lot of work
oh man
still top 30.
playing rage Hunter
attack
that much time to cool down after that
one
uh Play Bishop F4
What's Happening Here
I burned a lot of time
down the piece
some small chances
wow
what's happening now
oh let's check
Doh I got fort
Jack
ah I hung a rook
well played ah my 2800 reading
oh no
okay Life Goes On
I have to settle down a little bit
berserking again
oh we've played this line a few times
been getting nice positions
yeah like really nice positions
mailbox just a bit stuck here
still takes work
I didn't know what to do
yeah
letting this slip
okay I have to be careful I pre-move
this because King H7 Queen is stalemate
okay oh man
okay here we go again
so hour and 47 minutes left the E4
uh Carol convoir
yeah I've been having good success with
this sign
wow
yeah let's just blow up in the king side
and visual G5 uh
okay it's not that bad I'm down a piece
but there's still compensation I have
three pawns for the piece too
I've not lost a single Pawn yet
oops
okay it's not that bad
oh
foreign
okay
I was very fortunate there
oh man
27.99
so 564 tournament points
top 20 will be hard to get
berserk
not sure if this player berserks back
okay I guess not
Stafford Gambit Maybe
interesting
still playing in the style of the Saturn
uh
it has a little bit ugly though
E6
maybe it's not too bad
it is a confusing setup here
it takes takes if I take with Bishop
so this bishop defends D6 from a
distance
okay winning material
somehow this worked out
29 seconds
okay that was a cool game
like not quite a true staffer Gambit but
a lot of like similar ideas
okay
I'll play the sign
I'll reverse bernoni
[Music]
um
I've already gone wrong
okay maybe it's salvageable
not pleasant though
yeah it was just a bad ending
still trying to fight
down the pond
foreign
yeah a little bit too slow and too weak
there
good game though
I did plunger from the opening
okay 569
all right let's play English this time
I'm supposed to take with other Pawn
this is playable though
okay going for the vengeful D4
and D4 doesn't quite work
like D3
and double up Rooks behind the d-pawn
hmm
Queen is kind of getting stuck
that was a bad decision
all right Queen is just getting trapped
oh dear
there there okay let's try this
nothing works
uh good move
okay let's go for the one last trick
ah okay
two queens is too many
yeah my momentum has slowed down a
little bit
okay another staffer declined
uh
no just Bishop B7
so white has a bishop hair
and this would be okay
oh
[Music]
yeah we're both missing things
maybe it's still okay
I'm trying to trade
still under pressure though
idea of this
hey it's chaspara what's up Jasper
appreciate the rain
if you're just joining
I'm approaching the eight hour mark of
this stream
it's been a long one
approaching the final 93 minutes of this
tournament
trying to hold what looks to be a worse
ending but
I feel like this is holdable Maybe
96 coming
uh
I'm still worse here
but I have a knight which is known to be
sometimes preferable and
especially the the quicker the time
control
laughs
that's a good move
yeah this is big trouble
still trying
no
don't hurt me die I got hurt
good game
ah what to do
okay still still top 30.
uh do I raise berserk I guess I do
the only way to untilt
yeah my rating briefly crossed 2100
now doctor low
okay this is a pleasant position
it's easy to play quickly
I have the bishop hair
all right
foreign
fight
some F4 idea
can I take
maybe not
that's not good
still alive barely
not really though
my Bishop
okay bones having some mercy
those four Pawns
what to do
oh no my Rook
yeah GG
ah what to do
okay still top 30.
uh that's probably my longest losing
streak of the tournament
let's bounce happen at some point no
more berserking
uh even
when my opponent has just berserked I'm
gonna stay true to my word
uh and maybe try and reverse momentum
scandi time
uh yeah this line is fun
thank you Phoenix
C6
oh no
I've gone terribly wrong again
it's not too bad I got two pawns for the
piece
our phone's taking their sweet time
okay yeah the quality of play is really
going down
uh
and I'll only be down and exchange for a
pawn
wow
foreign
somehow
yeah that wasn't the best move
but maybe it's okay
I mean black has some issues here
oh no my queen
but actually my queen
after it takes C7 it's winning
okay
that was a cool topic
thank you chimpani thank you a cool
I've hovered around the same place
for a little bit now
uh no berserking let's try and like get
back on the streak
okay maybe next time if my opponent
berserk saw berserk back I feel kind of
bad
like taking timeouts
King D2 opponents going full rage mode
with the King
I feel slightly offended
okay
how to control the center
I didn't get to feeling cattle but that
was the idea of G6
to put the bishop on G7
okay my opponent berserks I berserve
back if they don't
then I don't okay
Stafford gather time
can't recall if I played this against
this opponent before
but we've gone into this line already a
few times
um
Bishop B6
I should have played this actually
I just want my Pawn Cube
pong Cube achieved
okay Bishop G2 is coming
oh
okay I'll take that
my Pawn Cube was indestructible that
game
okay let's get an ortho orthostnop
only played this like once or twice this
tournament
so the idea of the gamut is to just
really get a lot of development
um but it still takes work to
prove compensation
I'm down two Pawns
but black setup is a little bit awkward
careful
I'm gonna be down the pawn unfortunately
unless I play this
let's play this first
okay taking my sweet time to win back D3
if D2 I probably play King C2
yeah I'm still in trouble though
33 is coming I think I have to take
down two ponds black has a bishop hair
but I have a knight
a threatening actually to take in rookie
four
which is not happening
okay some counter play
oh good move
someone call an ambulance
for me
I'm pinned wait I have this move
I need some tricks
still exist
not over yet
before is a threat this is a threat
well there goes my Bishop
up a lot of time
now it's a pawn race
foreign
trying to calculate
let's go I went for the the end game
attack against the king
opposition
okay I was kind of dirty
I'll take it though
still 29th Place
throwing this
okay very positional game now
yeah it's a maneuvering game
foreign
here
okay lock finally cracked a little bit
oops
no I'm too slow ah what to do
a lot of good position too
it wasn't meant to be
thank you barkovsky the first time some
all right
I have to channel my rage into good
moves
foreign
nights have been misplaced so
it should be on F6
it's still some pleasant ideas here
Bishop G4 coming
okay the idea is after it takes I play
Knight D4
yeah this is very close to winning
just have to watch out about this Pawn
I'm up a lot of time here
interesting
okay
thank you barkowsky gifting to Darko
appreciate that
okay
here we go
this is a fun Line This is a
one of the tricks of early 95
um Black's doing okay still I think King
E7 was a better move
I'm back's a little bit flustered here
okay
I think uh Queen
wait a minute
I have to be careful with how I do this
idea is to play B4 also to take on G7
in this case I take on V8
assuming Rook B8 B4
if Knight C3 okay
yeah this is nice now
um
requires a little bit more care though
because Queen D6
I think it's better just to Castle first
that way I'm not having to deal with all
these checks
in the line where I take the Rook
okay the queen is almost trapped
but not quite
okay
I would like to Checkmate before
black flags might be hard to do though
maybe I should just play safe too
Rook C3
okay let's
Rook beef and wait a minute
the chuck
I've already gone terribly wrong Chuck
oh that's not good
will hurt me
okay my king will just run huh
Like the Wind
okay
not my proudest conversion
black got counter play there
okay will this stream be a YouTube video
yeah
um
this this stream combined with the
previous stream
will probably be about a 12 hour YouTube
video
so stay tuned
okay stop for gamma time
yeah this is one of the most basic traps
foreign
[Music]
just be solid
up a lot of time
thank you Alpha Fletcher
happy nine months
and Von's Von happy 13 months
oh let's check
I was ready to win the queen
wow fancy move
okay
still 29th oh there's a gap between me
and 30th
and if I win my next game I can LeapFrog
maybe to 26th Place
oh playing Soul tie
berserk Soul tie usually berserks back
but maybe not
okay
play one of these
wait what have I done
this is maybe okay
I got the bishop here
yeah soul Tai beat me
ages ago
about 20 hours ago maybe
I think we played a few times
Under Pressure here
uh Knight's almost trapped
somehow this works out
The Accidental tactics
I think it's Force mates
and it's gonna be made eventually but
no need to take the Rook
okay
a nice little pattern
so 26th Place leapfrogged a little bit
still very far from top 20 though
hour and five minutes to go
Stafford Gambit part 20 maybe
having a lot of Stafford thus far
we have the magical line
oh no my Bishop
yeah for a while Bishop F3 was like the
most recommended move
and this is completely winning for white
but in this time format it can still be
tricky
yeah so a lot of people walk into this
E5 line
or not a lot of people like this is a
very specific line but
uh I think black is already doing well
King G1 was a winning move
okay but how to actually win this
I take on I think just Bishop D5
The Bishop's pinned
F3 has to be played
okay let's checkmate
okay how many games have gone to like
this this full line
I looked at this actually a few days ago
I was trying to make these lines work
King G1 wins actually most people have
Fight King G1 E5 looks like so
attractive but after Queen F5
um yeah it's not so clear
like white has to be super super careful
you know Bishop D5 so if F3 Queen D3
I was just winning
King G1 oh wow King G1 Rook G2
Bishop F3
yeah winning the queen
okay
600.
got there with a Stafford
I played over 200 games thus far
I think this is a record for like most
games I've played in a single tournament
unless maybe maybe like a bullet
Marathon had more
okay I've kind of
with a different move order than what I
usually do
so this is a bit more positional
[Music]
I'd like to get an E4 at some point
maybe even D5
and black has some play on The Queen
side
like not the easiest position to play
I should make a looft
okay I trade Queens
so E5 now
could lead to a lot of Trades
how is my brain not fried yet
it feels kind of fried
but I'm just trying to have fun enjoy
the games
if I stopped having fun I'd probably
stopped streaming but
still enjoying things
the Rooks are about to have a lot of fun
on the seventh
oh but It's Tricky
wow black just in time
with boxing time
there
okay
H5 is a tricky move
the idea is to play H6
otherwise now I went off salon
okay I have a position earlier that I
really messed up
uh let me try not to mess this one up
oh yeah the king's getting mated
two different meat threats
there's one Chuck
maybe a few spy checks
thank you to vomberioca
happy three months
okay 24th Place
the most difficult thing is my hand is
kind of getting sore like holding the
mouse for so long
probably not that great for my fingers
okay well let's accept the
what do they call this nagmundson
haven't had a nagman son thus far
have I already gone wrong
and this moves
but then G4
I have no time
maybe it's okay though
foreign
[Music]
I have a vague memory of actually
studying this
take
I think I just played through all my
nagmanson prep from like ages ago
I hung upon though okay thanks for not
taking it
yeah The Rook will be on G7 defending
all the Pawns
no I repeated
that's a draw
oh I was in good shape someone that too
what to do
okay I've played 204 games so far
24th Place
a berserk
Stafford Gambit time
yeah this line is a good line for white
it was H3 line
but there's still some pressure
oh
pressure's Mountain
I think I just suck
Rook D4 coming
or not
at night's pinned
okay somehow that worked out
okay
been going back and forth with this
opponent
I don't think we played the sign yet
yeah under a bit of pressure here
[Music]
okay I want to take
because it's risky
I'm just losing a pawn
what to do
F5
Queen E5 Knight G4 queen of five not F2
still some tricks
wanna play F6 now
too tired to calculate everything
just do it and see what happens
so if it takes I take the queen take and
take the pawn
and maybe it's not so bad
I'm still probably a little bit worse
wait a minute do I have this move
and King G7 though
almost worked
if we have a rook ending
wow
good move
I have to play this
still may be okay
I'm just maybe
hold on to the pawn yeah this should be
a draw
might just offer a draw
unless black wants to play on
I'll offer Rook trade
wow vlog's playing on
okay
I'll draw like this
oh
okay I haven't lost a game in a while
will this be uploaded to YouTube
uh yes it might take a long time to
upload though it's gonna be a lot of
gigabytes
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
please like And subscribe
this is a small token for the amount of
effort it's going to take to post this
video to YouTube
okay defending the pawn
I kind of forgot that we both berserked
to be
I feel a little bit slow here
my position is very winning
like very winning
okay
opponent was kind of fast maybe I missed
something easier there
okay
I haven't seen this one before I think
E5 was a mouse slip
that's interesting though
are more interesting for white
again I'm a little bit slow but
trying to get the job done
I have a lot of Queens
okay
6 16.
oh playing Drago again
I usually like to play okay I'll lose it
back
going into one of these
I don't know what's happening
wait I'm just getting meat no I'm not
Queen here I Checkmate first
oh something's in my eye
oh it's irritating
wow
stop hurting me
no
no my thing I have a nice position too
what to do
I've had good games against Chicago
[Music]
my last scheme against this opponent
they walked their King to H5
let's see what they do this time
no there's like a t I still have some
coconut water
yeah this line doesn't strike the same
punch Bishop B7 is interesting
wow
okay so we have some end game battle or
queenless middle game
foreign
wants to draw
I want reading though
I mean I'm probably a little bit worse
here
but it's a three result game
the night will stand happily on D4
um
yeah this might turn sour very quickly
uh oh
yeah this is not good let's take
maybe some counter play
wow
and B4
some counter played
maybe I should have taken the draw but
maybe wait what is this
takes
wow so that works
um
Checkmate is that Checkmate that's
Checkmate wow it's checkmate
I found man in the morning
okay
it's just out of nowhere I wasn't even
thinking about checkmates
wow
okay that's why you turn down draw
offers
all right
B4 wasn't Checkmate because Rook takes
B4 and then I would be in check was some
discover check
try playing vovichas we have a Time
lifetime score
I think I just allow the capture
oops
we have a tactics are in my favor there
uh let's play this
it still takes work
this move
it's actually not so simple
yeah this is gonna be a mess
foreign
take side Knight F6
okay
there's a tornado warning
do people hear that
I have to run and probably take shelter
uh
wait we didn't repeat
what just happened
is there actually a tornado warning
tornado warning
take shelter now in a basement
ah I might have to leave for a moment
uh
just bear with me
I don't see any tornado out the window
which is maybe a good thing
let me just finish this game first
okay seven was so sneaky
yeah I hear the warning sirens I should
probably take shelter
doll my queen
stole my other thing
don't owe my time
okay I'm gonna uh run and make sure that
I don't get Swept Away by a tornado
uh BRB I guess
uh I mean look outside the window yeah
I'll be right back
uh pause
and
uh I can't really bring my stream setup
to the basement but what to do
uh BRB
maybe I'll be in chat
[Music]
okay
um I'm going to stay
in the basement
so bear with me one moment
Okay so
I'm gonna try and play the rest of the
marathon
from
my phone
and hopefully
I can set this up
I think it set up correctly though so
uh you guys can watch my games but I
will not be playing from this room so
anyway uh thanks for wishing me all the
best wishes and I'll be back hopefully
at some points
all right bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'm back
it's raining now but I think there's
less risk of a tornado so
I'm gonna try and
play the final minutes of the marathon
it's been a long long stream
uh let me close out my tab
okay oh I hope people enjoyed the
the no face
remote pentatonic
I got a fun stalemate traffic in Chicago
[Music]
uh
okay final few games
here we go
uh let's play this
we'll have some fun in the the final few
wait this isn't fun I am just losing a
pun
maybe it's okay
okay
I'm just gonna try and like play a game
and not blunder too much
it might already be worse for black
but it's interesting
okay
a lot of simplification
thank you Fang Duster
yeah whatever there's a tornado you got
to just stay calm
the only thing to do
I've been having a lot of Rook endings
okay I think F4 is a mistake
uh
uh of this move
[Music]
start with this
I think I'm still going to be winning a
pawn
yeah winning one of these guys
and this should be a draw but you never
know
okay
maybe some chances
maybe not
can try and grind this one
not making any progress
foreign
wow
okay
oh
there's a lot of rain outside I'm using
a noise suppression filter so people
probably don't hear it
but it's kind of loud
I think this will be the final game
maybe one more after this
no draw
I'm losing upon
or am I
of this move
Doh okay
yeah
dull my queen
[Music]
you never know
oh I'm so
so disappointed okay
oh opponent gave me the queen
just a little bit too slow
okay
um
well that's the tournament
it's over for me
I finished top 30.
officially it ends in 15 seconds
there were over 24 000 players
I streamed
I mean this stream alone was over nine
hours
I stream for almost three hours
uh last night so streamed about half of
it uh this will probably be a 12 hour
YouTube video
I think the limit is 12 hours for
YouTube uploads so maybe just below 12
hours
uh let's refresh
congratulations Aqua blazing
do I played a few times we had some fun
games
uh thanks everyone for watching
one more to say
um if you're watching in the future on
YouTube let me know your favorite game
in the timestamps I played
220 games
I lost some reading
but I survived the tornado
at least so far